Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Dr Liar, Dr Mockery, the sycophantic scoundrel, the over-educated wretch, the arch-wretch, the clever snake, the cunning fox, the rabid fox, the malicious black raven, the arrogant, puffed up, spiteful dragon, a godless mound of flesh, the arch heathen, the arch devil, a crook, a flatterer, an atheist, a pope, a monk. So, Tom, those are just some of the things that people on Twitter have called you. I don't think it's me, Dominic. You knew that was coming.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。谎言博士、嘲弄博士、阿谀奉承的无赖、受过过度教育的卑鄙小人、大无赖、聪明的毒蛇、狡猾的狐狸、狂犬般的狐狸、恶毒的黑乌鸦、傲慢自大、心胸狭窄的恶龙、无神论的肉堆、大异教徒、大魔鬼、骗子、奉承者、无神论者、教皇、僧侣。汤姆，这些只是推特上人们对你的称呼。多米尼克，我觉得那不是我。你知道这迟早会发生。
The godless mound of flesh. So, yeah, the monk, though. Yeah, maybe. All of that stuff, yeah. Overeducated wretch. Listen, these are words, Tom, that were used to describe Martin Luther, who we've been talking about on the rest of this history, a man who changed the way that Europeans thought about themselves, their place in the universe,
无神论的肉堆。好吧，那个僧侣，确实。是的，也许吧。所有这些，是的。受过过度教育的卑鄙小人。听着，汤姆，这些词是用来形容马丁·路德的，我们一直在《历史的余味》中谈论他，一个改变了欧洲人对自己、对他们在宇宙中位置的看法的人，
their relationship to God and to each other. An arrow from a pamphlet that was published in November 1524, and it was called A Highly Provoked Defense and Answer to the Spiritless Soft Living Flesh at Wittenberg, who has most lamentably befouled pitiable Christianity in a perverted way by his theft of holy scripture. Punchy title. Very punchy. So we are in episode five now of this epic series about the life and times of Martin Luther.
以及他们与上帝和彼此之间的关系。摘自1524年11月出版的一本小册子，书名是《对维滕贝格无精打采、生活安逸的肉体的强烈辩护与回答》，他因窃取圣经而以一种扭曲的方式极其可悲地玷污了可怜的基督教。标题很有冲击力。非常有冲击力。所以我们现在进入了这个关于马丁·路德生平与时代的史诗系列的第五集。
And we've got up to 1524, which is when this pamphlet is published. So to give people a sense, he's hammered his theses to the wall of the church, or not, depending on what you believe. He's been summoned to a series of interrogations. He's gone to the Diet of Worms
我们已经讲到了1524年，也就是这本小册子出版的时候。为了让大家有个概念，他把自己的论文钉在了教堂墙上，或者没钉，取决于你相信什么。他被传唤进行了一系列审讯。他去了沃尔姆斯议会
to plead his case before the emperor. He's been declared a heretic. He's been kidnapped and stored in this tower where he's murdered a dog. And now we're in 1524. He's a hate figure to the Catholics of Europe. But the man who's written this is not a Catholic, actually.
在皇帝面前为自己辩护。他被宣布为异端。他被绑架并关进了这座塔里，在那里他杀死了一条狗。现在是1524年。他是欧洲天主教徒眼中的仇恨对象。但写这东西的人其实不是天主教徒。
He's a man who thinks that Luther is a backslider and an appeaser of potpourri. So tell us about the guy who's written this. So the guy who's written this, he's a guy called Thomas Munzer. He was a follower of Luther. He'd met with Luther in 1519. Luther had actually recommended him for a job as a preacher. And you might think that the two men have a lot in common because like Luther, Munzer thinks that a true Christian must be born again.
他认为路德是一个倒退者，是一个向教皇制度妥协的人。那么给我们介绍一下写这东西的人吧。写这东西的人叫托马斯·闵采尔。他是路德的追随者。他曾在1519年见过路德。路德实际上还推荐他担任传教士的工作。你可能会认为这两个人有很多共同点，因为像路德一样，闵采尔认为真正的基督徒必须重生。
So he writes that each person must receive the Holy Spirit in a sevenfold way. Otherwise, he neither hears nor understands the living God. Like Luther, he believes in a division between those who have been born again, a kind of elect, and those Christians who you brilliantly called Chinos, Christians in names only. Yeah, Very good. And like Luther, as you could see from the title of that pamphlet, where he's describing befouling, pitiful Christianity. In a perverted way.
所以他写道，每个人都必须以七重方式接受圣灵。否则，他既听不到也理解不了活着的上帝。像路德一样，他相信那些已经重生的人（一种选民）与你精彩地称为“名义基督徒”（Chinos）的基督徒之间存在区别。是的，非常好。而且像路德一样，正如你从那本小册子的标题中看到的，他描述了玷污、可怜的基督教。以一种扭曲的方式。
Yes. He loves to abuse Catholics, traditional theologians, so he calls them donkey farts. Nice. Diarrhea makers. And he describes them as being scrotum like what is it with germans in the 16th century and their bowels i don't know what does this say about their daily experience that they you know the most enlightened men men who spend all their time thinking about the Holy Spirit, reach so readily, Tom, for the scatological comparison? Well, I think that, I mean, it's something to do with the violence of what they're doing,
是的。他喜欢辱骂天主教徒和传统神学家，所以他称他们为“驴屁”。不错。还有“腹泻制造者”。他形容他们像阴囊一样。16世纪的德国人到底怎么了，为什么总是提到肠道？我不知道，这说明了他们日常生活的什么情况？你知道，最开明的人，那些整天思考圣灵的人，汤姆，为什么这么容易就用排泄物做比喻？嗯，我想，这与他们所做之事的暴力性有关，
I think. Right. They are kind of tearing down, they're launching attacks on this mighty edifice, and perhaps they just need to kind of rev themselves up. You know, it's a kind of linguistic dose of Red Bull or something. Right. I don't know, but I think that the violence of what they're doing is replicated in the violence of their language. Because Munzer, like Luther, is a man who is ready to take on those in authority.
我想。对。他们正在拆毁，他们正在对这座宏伟的建筑发起攻击，也许他们只是需要让自己振作起来。你知道，这就像是一种语言上的红牛饮料之类的东西。对。我不知道，但我认为他们所做之事的暴力性在他们语言的暴力性中得到了复制。因为闵采尔和路德一样，是一个准备挑战权威的人。
And in 1524, that same year that Munzer has launched this attack against Luther, an uprising is happening that is going to convulse the whole of Germany. So it begins on the 30th of May, 1524, when the tenants of an abbey in the Black Forest, so that's in southern Germany, refuse to pay their landlord. And people who listened to our episode on the Peasants' Revolt may remember that similar things were happening and that it precipitated a general uprising because this resentment of predatory monasteries and abbeys, it was a feature in 14th century England and it's a feature of 16th century Germany. Yeah. So just on that, Tom, I suppose Dearman McCulloch in his great book on the Reformation makes the point that that Peasants' War, which is actually much bigger than the Peasants' Revolt, isn't it?
而在1524年，也就是闵采尔对路德发起攻击的同一年，一场即将震撼整个德国的起义正在发生。它始于1524年5月30日，当时黑森林（德国南部）一座修道院的佃农拒绝向他们的地主交租。听过我们关于农民起义那一集的人可能还记得，类似的事情也曾发生过，并引发了一场普遍的起义，因为这种对掠夺性修道院的怨恨，是14世纪英国的一个特征，也是16世纪德国的一个特征。是的。关于这一点，汤姆，我想迪尔曼·麦卡洛克在他关于宗教改革的伟大著作中指出，那场“农民战争”（实际上比“农民起义”规模大得多，不是吗？）
I mean, it's much more convulsive than the Peasants' Revolt in England. Yeah. That it partly comes out of that thing we were talking about in an earlier episode, which is this extraordinary apocalyptic mood in the early 16th century, and particularly the 1520s. So people are terrified about the Ottomans, that they're going to kind of sweep up through Central Europe and wipe Christendom from the map. But also, obviously, since Luther's come along, that sense of kind of apocalyptic chaos and flux has become even more intense. So people are questioning everything.
我的意思是，它比英国的农民起义更具震撼力。是的。它部分源于我们在前一集谈到的那种东西，即16世纪初，特别是1520年代那种非凡的末日情绪。所以人们对奥斯曼帝国感到恐惧，担心他们会横扫中欧并将基督教从地图上抹去。但显然，自从路德出现以来，那种末日混乱和动荡的感觉变得更加强烈。所以人们在质疑一切。
And McCulloch in his book says there's been loads of kind of copycat destructive violence. So this goes back to the comparison that you made in the previous episode with the 2020s, where there have been people smashing up relics and smashing up images. There's a famous example in Riga, also in 1524, where people take this big statue of a witch. Sorry, they don't take a big statue of a witch. Such a Protestant. They take a big statue of the Virgin Mary. That's the most Protestant sentence that's ever been said. Same difference.
麦卡洛克在他的书中说，发生了大量的模仿性破坏暴力。这回到了你在上一集中与2020年代所做的比较，当时有人砸毁圣物和图像。1524年在里加有一个著名的例子，人们拿走了一尊巨大的女巫雕像。抱歉，他们拿走的不是女巫雕像。真是个新教徒。他们拿走了一尊圣母玛利亚的雕像。这是有史以来最像新教徒的一句话。意思一样。
Well, that's what they say. They say it's a statue of a witch. They throw it in the river and it doesn't sink. So they then take it out the river and they set it on fire and they burn it. And there's this sort of sense, he calls them the years of carnival. There's this sense of, you know, all bets are are off all the shackles have been released completely and as you said the peasants thing it's actually quite similar to the peasants revolt because some of the leaders of it are kind of respectable aspirational people yeah who don't as you said they're sick of being bossed
嗯，他们就是这么说的。他们说那是一尊女巫雕像。他们把它扔进河里，它没有沉下去。于是他们把它从河里捞出来，放火烧了它。有一种感觉，他称之为“狂欢节的岁月”。有一种感觉，你知道，一切都结束了，所有的枷锁都被完全释放了。正如你所说，农民起义的事情实际上和农民起义非常相似，因为其中的一些领导人是那种受人尊敬、有抱负的人，是的，他们正如你所说，厌倦了被地主（那些僧侣或教会）指手画脚。
around by the landlords who are monks or kind of collegiate churches. And those tensions which were always there have become supercharged by the apocalyptic atmosphere of the day. Yeah, absolutely. But Dominic, not only by the apocalyptic atmosphere, also very specifically by Luther's theology, because he is talking about Christian freedom, the idea that every Christian can be free. And of course, that provides a ready battle cry for the rebels. And what is more, his insistence on sola scriptura, the idea that nothing is necessary unless it is specifically mentioned in scripture, provides them with all kinds of sanctions for rebelling, say, against serfdom, which is not mentioned in the Bible. So they publish a
而那些一直存在的紧张关系，被当时末日的氛围所加剧了。是的，绝对。但多米尼克，不仅是因为末日的氛围，还特别是因为路德的神学，因为他在谈论基督徒的自由，即每个基督徒都可以自由的理念。当然，这为叛军提供了一个现成的战斗口号。而且，他坚持“唯独圣经”（sola scriptura），即除非圣经中有明确提及，否则一切都是不必要的，这为他们反抗农奴制（圣经中未提及）提供了各种制裁依据。所以他们在1525年早春发布了一份
manifesto in the early spring of 1525, and they are, as Luther had done, repeatedly appealing to the Bible as a source of legitimacy for what they're doing. And this is the key demand, the demand that serfdom be abolished, as true and just Christians release us in a spirit of joy from our servitude, or else show us from the gospel that we should be serfs. So that's exactly Luther's strategy. And of course, there's nothing in the gospels that says they should be serfs. And so this inspires, I mean, certainly helps to inspire this massive movement because I guess the difference between England is that you have London is the focus. So if you move on London, then that's all there is. But in Germany, as we've said,
宣言，他们像路德所做的那样，反复诉诸圣经作为他们行为合法性的来源。这是关键要求，即废除农奴制，因为真正公正的基督徒会以喜乐的精神将我们从奴役中释放出来，否则就从福音书中向我们证明我们应该成为农奴。这正是路德的策略。当然，福音书中没有任何地方说他们应该成为农奴。所以这激发了，我的意思是，肯定有助于激发这场大规模运动，因为我想英国和德国的区别在于，英国是以伦敦为中心。所以如果你向伦敦进军，那就是全部了。但在德国，正如我们所说，
it's this patchwork of different states, different cities, and so on. And so you are having eruptions of rebellion across the entire fabric of the empire. And by the spring of 1525, it has reached Saxony and Thuringia, which of course is Wittenberg, where Luther is based, is in Saxony, but it's also where Munzer is based. So he is in a town called Mulhausen, which is in Thuringia. And Munzer, I mean, he's all in. So he forms his own armed militia, which he modestly calls the Eternal League of God. That's a great name for a militia, to be fair. He does what I would certainly do if I were leading a rebellion. I would arrange for a huge white flag to serve as its banner and put a rainbow on it. Oh my word. That's very 2020s. Very 2024, isn't it? Yeah, it is. But it also has the very Lutheran slogan on it, may the word of God endure forever.
这是一个由不同邦国、不同城市等组成的拼凑体。所以你在整个帝国的版图上都在爆发叛乱。到1525年春天，它已经蔓延到萨克森和图林根，当然，路德所在的维滕贝格就在萨克森，但这也是闵采尔的基地。所以他在一个叫米尔豪森的城镇，位于图林根。闵采尔，我的意思是，他全力以赴。所以他组建了自己的武装民兵，他谦虚地称之为“上帝的永恒联盟”。说实话，这真是个好名字。如果我是叛军领袖，我肯定会做他做的事。我会安排一面巨大的白旗作为旗帜，上面画一道彩虹。天哪。那太2020年代了。非常2024年，不是吗？是的，确实。但上面也有非常路德派的口号：愿上帝的话语永存。
Yeah. So, Munster has this huge great flag. It's got a rainbow. He's got a tremendous name for his army. And on the 11th of May, 1525, he and his troops rendezvous with another great squadron of rebels outside a place called Frankenhausen. And there they meet with an army. And at the head of that army is the brother of Frederick the Wise, the protector of Luther, but who is a Catholic, Duke George of Saxony. And so this is a confrontation between very radical evangelicals, very radical people who are rejecting the Church of Rome and Catholics. And I guess from the point of view of the evangelicals, this is a confrontation with the forces of Antichrist that is threatening more violence. It's more direct than even Luther's confrontation with the emperor at Worms.
是的。所以，闵采尔有这面巨大的旗帜。上面有彩虹。他的军队有个了不起的名字。1525年5月11日，他和他的部队在弗兰肯豪森外与另一支伟大的叛军中队会合。在那里，他们遇到了一支军队。那支军队的统帅是弗雷德里克的兄弟，路德的保护者，但他是个天主教徒，萨克森公爵乔治。所以这是一场极端的福音派、拒绝罗马教会的激进分子与天主教徒之间的对抗。我想从福音派的角度来看，这是与威胁要带来更多暴力的反基督势力的对抗。这比路德在沃尔姆斯与皇帝的对抗更直接。
And this is the first time, right, Tom, that the emerging splits, people would not have used these words in 1524 between Catholics and Protestants. This is the first time that it's become a religious war. I mean, genuinely a battle. Yeah, a military confrontation. So if we think about Luther, where does he stand on this? He does not approve of it at all. And the reason that Munzer is lambasting Luther with all those abusive words and phrases that you were quoting at the beginning is that he views Luther as dragging his feet. A puffed up spiteful dragon, Tom. Yeah. He hasn't gone far enough. The thing about this, of course, I mean, it's a very, very familiar trend that someone can take a revolutionary position, a radical position, and then find themselves outflanked by people who
这是第一次，对吧，汤姆，新兴的分裂（人们在1524年不会用这些词）在天主教徒和新教徒之间。这是第一次演变成宗教战争。我的意思是，真正意义上的战斗。是的，军事对抗。所以如果我们想到路德，他对此持什么立场？他一点也不赞成。闵采尔用你开头引用的那些辱骂性的词汇和短语抨击路德的原因是，他认为路德在拖后腿。一个傲慢自大的恶龙，汤姆。是的。他走得还不够远。当然，关于这一点，我的意思是，这是一个非常非常熟悉的趋势，一个人可以采取革命性的立场，激进的立场，然后发现自己被走得更远、更远、更远的人所超越。
are going further and further and further. So we're very familiar with that today. Luther, for five years, from the moment where he had nailed the theses to the door in Wittenberg, basically up to his return to Wittenberg from the Wartburg. He has been a kind of lightning rod for rebellion beyond anything that Christendom had ever seen. But now the revolution has overtaken him. And essentially, with his return to Wittenberg from the Wartburg, where he'd been kept by Frederick the Wise, he goes from being celebrated as a revolutionary to being damned by many of his followers as a reactionary. And this conflict is really focused on two figures. So,
所以我们今天对这一点非常熟悉。路德，从他在维滕贝格门上钉下论文的那一刻起，到他从瓦尔特堡回到维滕贝格，整整五年，他一直是基督教界前所未见的叛乱的避雷针。但现在革命已经超越了他。本质上，随着他从瓦尔特堡回到维滕贝格（他曾被弗雷德里克关在那里），他从被誉为革命者变成了被许多追随者诅咒为反动派。这种冲突确实集中在两个人物身上。所以，
Munzer is one of them, and we'll come to the precise relationship between Luther and Munzer. But before that, people may remember in our previous episode that the guy who is leading the Reformation in Wittenberg while Luther is away in the Wartburg is a guy called Andreas Karlstadt. So he was the guy who was like the vice-chancellor of the university or something. He was the chancellor and he'd been the chancellor since he was 25. So he's a brilliant, brilliant man. And he'd married a four-year-old or something. No, not quite. He'd married a nun. But yes, so he has pushed things to the extreme and Luther is appalled. And Luther is appalled by this, I think, for kind of personal reasons. It's resentment of a man who he'd always seen as his follower. There's anxiety that all the chaos and the rioting that Karlstadt moves to kind of smash up images and all that kind of thing has precipitated that this will alienate Frederick, the Elector of Saxony, who's Luther's great patron.
闵采尔是其中之一，我们将谈到路德和闵采尔之间的确切关系。但在那之前，人们可能还记得在上一集中，当路德在瓦尔特堡时，领导维滕贝格宗教改革的人是一个叫安德烈亚斯·卡尔施塔特的人。所以他就是那个大学副校长之类的。他是校长，而且他从25岁起就是校长了。所以他是一个非常非常聪明的人。而且他娶了一个四岁的孩子还是什么的。不，没那么夸张。他娶了一个修女。但是的，所以他把事情推向了极端，路德感到震惊。路德对此感到震惊，我想，是出于某种个人原因。这是对一个他一直视为追随者的人的怨恨。他担心卡尔施塔特那种砸毁图像等混乱和骚乱行为会疏远萨克森选侯弗雷德里克，他是路德伟大的赞助人。
And as Luther sees it, the patron and defender of the Reformation itself. So Luther is actually, funnily enough, for somebody who's not a politician, he's playing the sensible, pragmatic practitioner of politics saying, listen, we can't afford to alienate our powerful patron. Right. He does not want to defund the police, I think would be the way of saying, he recognises that you need someone to back you up, to maintain law and order. And inevitably also there are big theological arguments. And the biggest one is around transubstantiation. Luther argues that
正如路德所见，他是宗教改革本身的赞助人和捍卫者。所以路德实际上，有趣的是，对于一个不是政治家的人来说，他扮演了一个理智、务实的政治实践者的角色，说：听着，我们不能疏远我们强大的赞助人。对。他不想削减警察经费，我想这应该是表达方式，他认识到你需要有人支持你，以维持法律和秩序。不可避免地，还有重大的神学争论。最大的一个围绕着“变体论”。路德认为
Christ is literally in the bread and wine given at the Eucharist, and Karl Schacht argues that Christ is literally in the bread and wine given at the Eucharist, and Karl Schacht argues that it isn't. And people may think, well, why are they arguing about whether something can change into something else? But I mean, you just have to look at, is a trans woman a woman? I mean, these are debates that are massively polarizing. People get terribly angry and upset about it on both sides. I mean, we use almost exactly the same metaphors, the same language, the same degree of intensity
基督确实存在于圣餐中给予的面包和酒中，而卡尔施塔特认为基督确实存在于圣餐中给予的面包和酒中，而卡尔施塔特认为他不在。人们可能会想，好吧，他们为什么要争论某样东西是否可以变成另一样东西？但我的意思是，你只需要看看，跨性别女性是女性吗？我的意思是，这些辩论是极具两极分化的。人们在双方都对此感到非常愤怒和不安。我的意思是，我们几乎使用了完全相同的隐喻，相同的语言，相同的强度
to the debate, don't we? I mean, I think there are kind of intriguing parallels there. But of course, the debate here is about the destiny of your mortal soul. So in a sense, the stakes are even higher, quantitatively higher. So when Luther comes back to Wittenberg from the Wartburg, I mean, he's determined to smash this upstart rebellion. So as we have explored throughout this series, I mean, he's brilliant at invective. So he targets Karlstadt personally, who had been one of his closest friends and supporters. Luther says of Karlstadt, he is a treacherous secret devil who sneaks around in corners until he has done his damage and spread his poison.
来辩论，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为这里有某种有趣的相似之处。但当然，这里的辩论是关于你凡人灵魂的命运。所以从某种意义上说，风险在数量上更高。所以当路德从瓦尔特堡回到维滕贝格时，我的意思是，他决心粉碎这场暴发户式的叛乱。正如我们在整个系列中所探讨的那样，我的意思是，他擅长谩骂。所以他针对卡尔施塔特个人，他曾是他最亲密的朋友和支持者之一。路德说卡尔施塔特：他是一个阴险的秘密魔鬼，躲在角落里，直到他造成了破坏并散布了他的毒药。
Inevitably, there is excrement-based abuse. So he accused Karlstadt of flinging excrement around. And Karlstadt, understandably, feels humiliated, but also very angry. Did he think Luther was going to back him up? Is he surprised by this? I think he did, yes, because Luther initially had said, brilliant, go for it, and then had swung against him when he realised it had gone too far. So Karlstadt basically gives up university life. He feels that his calling is no longer to be a scholar. But a full-time activist and practitioner of kindness. Well, so he gives up all his doctoral titles. Oh, God. And Luther then continues to misclass him, I guess you could say, by very ostentatiously calling him Dr. Karlstadt, which he does for the rest of his life.
不可避免地，有基于排泄物的辱骂。所以他指责卡尔施塔特到处乱扔排泄物。卡尔施塔特可以理解地感到羞辱，但也非常愤怒。他以为路德会支持他吗？他对此感到惊讶吗？我想他确实是，是的，因为路德最初说，太棒了，去做吧，然后当他意识到事情做得太过分时，他就转而反对他了。所以卡尔施塔特基本上放弃了大学生活。他觉得他的使命不再是成为一名学者。而是一名全职的活动家和善良的实践者。好吧，所以他放弃了他所有的博士头衔。天哪。然后路德继续贬低他，我想你可以这么说，通过非常显眼地称他为“卡尔施塔特博士”，他余生都这么做。
He calls himself Brother Andreas. I mean, this is so... Yeah, it's all very familiar. It's unbelievable how current it feels. Right. And those parallels are not tendentious because the ideals and the impulses that are being born in this period are absolutely what feed through into the universities of Protestant Britain and America as they were. So by 1523, Karlstadt has had enough of Wittenberg and Luther. So he takes up a post as a humble village priest in a town in Thuringia, about 100 miles southwest of Wittenberg. It's a place called Ullermunde.
他称自己为“安德烈亚斯兄弟”。我的意思是，这太……是的，这一切都非常熟悉。感觉如此现代，令人难以置信。对。而且这些相似之处并非偏颇，因为在这一时期诞生的理想和冲动绝对是滋养了新教英国和美国大学的养分。所以到1523年，卡尔施塔特受够了维滕贝格和路德。所以他在图林根的一个小镇担任了一名卑微的乡村牧师，距离维滕贝格西南约100英里。那个地方叫乌勒蒙德。
And here he institutes the reforms that Luther had abolished in Wittenberg. So Eucharist is given. There's no physical presence of Christ in it, no images, no music. So this is something Karlstadt is very big on. No music. Yeah, so Luther loves music. Luther is a great hymn writer. His hymns are key ways in which he spreads the Reformation. Karlstadt sees this as Babylonian practices, can't have that. And Luther continues to persecute him. So he amazingly, considering all the battle against censorship that
在这里，他实施了路德在维滕贝格废除的改革。所以圣餐被给予。基督没有实体存在，没有图像，没有音乐。所以这是卡尔施塔特非常看重的一点。没有音乐。是的，所以路德热爱音乐。路德是一位伟大的赞美诗作者。他的赞美诗是他传播宗教改革的关键方式。卡尔施塔特认为这是巴比伦式的做法，不能有那个。路德继续迫害他。所以他令人惊讶地，考虑到所有反对审查制度的斗争，
Luther had been involved in, he tries to get Karlstadt censored. And Karlstadt had been the second most published reformer after Luther. So it's a big deal. However, Karlstadt can still be published in Switzerland because that's outside the power. But essentially, Luther is invoking the power of the emperor to stop his erstwhile lieutenant from being published. It's just unbelievable. I can't get over the parallels. You know, we're not actually practicing cancel culture. We're the victims of cancel culture. I mean, this is basically what Luther and Karlstadt are saying to each other, right? Absolutely. And Luther just plays very, very hard and very, very dirty in the way that people embroiled in today's culture wars do. But I mean, Luther has the advantage that he has an elector,
路德曾参与其中，他试图让卡尔施塔特受到审查。而卡尔施塔特是继路德之后出版作品第二多的改革者。所以这很重要。然而，卡尔施塔特仍然可以在瑞士出版，因为那不在权力范围内。但本质上，路德正在援引皇帝的权力来阻止他以前的副手被出版。这简直令人难以置信。我无法克服这些相似之处。你知道，我们实际上并没有在实践“取消文化”。我们是“取消文化”的受害者。我的意思是，这基本上就是路德和卡尔施塔特在对彼此说的话，对吧？绝对。而且路德在今天文化战争中卷入的人所用的方式上，玩得非常非常狠，非常非常脏。但我的意思是，路德有优势，因为他有一位选侯，
an imperial elector on his side. So he is able to persuade Frederick to banish Karlstadt from Saxony altogether. And poor Karlstadt, I mean, his wife has just given birth. He's kind of wandering around with this newborn baby. I mean, kind of absolutely terrible time. But I guess rather like St. Francis perhaps, or earlier Catholic saints, he discovers God's purpose in his poverty. And he comes to identify the Reformation with a reaction not just against the Pope, but against the feudal order, against those who are rich. And he repents of his own role. Again, this is very familiar. He repents of his own role in exploitation, in frameworks of oppression. So he says, I have eaten from the labours of the poor
一位帝国选侯站在他这边。所以他能够说服弗雷德里克将卡尔施塔特完全逐出萨克森。可怜的卡尔施塔特，我的意思是，他的妻子刚生完孩子。他带着这个新生儿到处流浪。我的意思是，真是太糟糕了。但我猜就像圣方济各或者早期的天主教圣徒一样，他在贫困中发现了上帝的旨意。他开始将宗教改革不仅视为对教皇的反应，而且是对封建秩序、对那些富有者的反应。他忏悔自己所扮演的角色。同样，这非常熟悉。他忏悔自己在剥削、压迫框架中所扮演的角色。所以他说，我吃了穷人的劳动成果，
while giving them nothing in return in his role as chancellor of the university. And there's someone who had been able to get tithes from the poor. And so he starts wearing the grey of a peasant. He starts saying, I wish I'd been born a peasant. And he briefly lives as one. He becomes a farmer. And Luther finds this hilarious and mocks him viciously, rather in the way that people have mocked academics who pretend to be Native Americans or black people or whatever in America, white people doing that. Yeah. So Luther says of Karlstadt, he's opted for humility and civility, behavior which God does not remotely command, and all because he wants to be seen and praised and is an exceptional kind of Christian. And I think that that idea that you get closer to God by casting aside your
却在担任大学校长期间没有给他们任何回报。而且有人能够从穷人那里获得什一税。所以他开始穿上农民的灰色衣服。他开始说，我希望我出生时就是个农民。他短暂地过着那样的生活。他成为了一名农民。路德觉得这很滑稽，并恶毒地嘲笑他，就像人们嘲笑那些假装是美洲原住民或黑人或什么的学者一样，白人那样做。是的。所以路德说卡尔施塔特：他选择了谦卑和文明，这是上帝根本没有命令的行为，而这一切只是因为他想被看见和赞美，是一个特殊的基督徒。我认为那种通过抛弃你的
privilege and becoming an ally, this is the wellsprings of all that. And people today may not define themselves as Protestants, may not be doing it in the framework of a kind of understanding of God, but the sociological and cultural DNA is still absolutely there. It's unbelievable, Tom. I mean, you're literally talking about a man who is in a high status, respectable, incredibly respectable job job has given up his university degrees said i'm going to devote myself to full-time activism yeah and live like an ally with the poor and then his old mate is basically writing editorials for the daily express saying yeah look at this hypocrites look at this terrible man like because luther by this point of course
特权并成为盟友来更接近上帝的想法，这就是这一切的源头。今天的人们可能不会定义自己为新教徒，可能不会在某种对上帝的理解框架内这样做，但社会学和文化基因绝对还在那里。这令人难以置信，汤姆。我的意思是，你说的简直是一个处于高地位、受人尊敬、极其受人尊敬的工作的人，放弃了他的大学学位，说我要致力于全职活动，
has given up his cassock and has started developing a real taste for fine robes right brilliant so the two men do meet up again there's a famous meeting between them in a pub called the black bear inn in jena right so um carlstadt is there in his peasant gray and luther turns up you know swanking around in his robes. And they have a big debate, which is kind of inconclusive. And then during the peasants' war, Karlstadt is in real danger from both sides because the nobility obviously view him as a traitor. The peasants are suspicious of him as someone from a well-educated background. And so he ends up amazingly taking refuge with Luther.
并像盟友一样与穷人生活在一起，然后他的老伙计基本上在为《每日快报》写社论说，是的，看看这些伪君子，看看这个可怕的人，因为路德到这个时候当然已经放弃了他的法衣，并开始对华丽的长袍产生了真正的品味，对吧，太棒了。所以这两个人确实又见面了，他们在耶拿一家叫“黑熊旅馆”的酒吧里有一次著名的会面，对吧？所以，卡尔施塔特穿着他的农民灰衣服在那里，路德出现了，你知道，穿着他的长袍招摇过市。他们进行了一场大辩论，结果是不了了之。然后在农民战争期间，卡尔施塔特处于双方的真正危险之中，因为贵族显然视他为叛徒。农民则怀疑他是一个受过良好教育背景的人。所以他最终令人惊讶地向路德寻求庇护。
Oh my word. And Luther takes him in, but predictably does not squander the opportunity to completely humiliate him. So he makes Karlstadt write a full recantation of his views on the Eucharist. In exchange for his dinner or something. Exactly.
天哪。路德收留了他，但不出所料，没有浪费机会彻底羞辱他。所以他让卡尔施塔特写了一份关于圣餐观点的全面悔过书。为了换取他的晚餐还是什么的。正是如此。
Yeah, well, for shelter, you know, to keep him safe. And Luther persuades Frederick to revoke the order of banishment that Luther himself had encouraged Frederick initially to issue, but demands that Karlstadt live outside Wittenberg, which in turn means that Karlstadt doesn't have any kind of means of sustenance. So he has to live as a farmer again. He occasionally works as a peddler, and he's not allowed either to publish or to preach. In the end, he has enough of this. In 1529, he leaves Wittenberg. He goes to Switzerland, where the Reformation is fully ablaze, taking paths that are far distant from Luther and his influence. In Switzerland, he seems a marginal and broken figure. He he dies in 1541 of the plague.
是的，好吧，为了住所，你知道，为了保证他的安全。路德说服弗雷德里克撤销了路德本人最初鼓励弗雷德里克发布的驱逐令，但要求卡尔施塔特住在维滕贝格之外，这意味着卡尔施塔特没有任何维持生计的手段。所以他不得不再次像农民一样生活。他偶尔做小贩，也不被允许出版或传教。最后，他受够了。1529年，他离开维滕贝格。他去了瑞士，那里的宗教改革正如火如荼，走着远不同于路德及其影响的道路。在瑞士，他似乎是一个边缘化和破碎的人物。他于1541年死于瘟疫。
And there is much gloating about this in Lutheran circles. And they tell a terrible story that a strange, tall, thin man had appeared to Karlsdott's son three days before saying that he was the devil and he was coming to get Karlsdott. And sure enough, three days later, this tall, thin man is seen leading Karlschnatt away. I'm sure that definitely happened. By the hand. Right. So you might think he's a broken marginal figure who most people haven't heard of. Does he really matter? Okay. But I think for the reasons that we've been discussing, he does, because I think he establishes trends that are with us to this day. And we may not be aware of where they come from,
在路德派圈子里，对此有很多幸灾乐祸。他们讲了一个可怕的故事，说在卡尔施塔特死前三天，一个奇怪的、高瘦的男人出现在他儿子面前，说他是魔鬼，他是来抓卡尔施塔特的。果然，三天后，这个高瘦的男人被看到牵着卡尔施塔特的手把他带走了。我敢肯定那绝对发生了。牵着手。对。所以你可能认为他是一个破碎的边缘人物，大多数人没听说过。他真的重要吗？好吧。但我认为出于我们一直在讨论的原因，他很重要，因为我认为他确立了至今仍伴随着我们的趋势。我们可能没有意识到它们来自哪里，
but at least in part, it's coming from this nexus between Luther and Karlstadt. So Karlstadt had always admired Luther. And I think that this is why he goes back to him in the Peasants' War. He's like a kind of moth being drawn to the flame. But he is willing to follow the implications of Luther's Reformation to extremes that Luther himself does not want to go. He doesn't want to go there. The key thing, I think, for the development of the Netherlands, Britain, and America is that Karlstadt is a big influence on the Swiss Reformation that via Calvin and so on will influence all of those Protestant powers right the way into the modern day. And the key thing that Karlstadt argues,
但至少在某种程度上，它来自路德和卡尔施塔特之间的这种联系。所以卡尔施塔特一直很钦佩路德。我认为这就是为什么他在农民战争中回到他身边。他就像一只被火焰吸引的飞蛾。但他愿意将路德宗教改革的含义推向路德本人不想去的极端。他不想去那里。我认为对荷兰、英国和美国的发展来说，关键在于卡尔施塔特对瑞士宗教改革有很大影响，而瑞士宗教改革通过加尔文等人将影响所有这些新教大国，一直延续到现代。而卡尔施塔特争论的关键点，
which Luther rejects, is the idea that God's law matters more than earthly law, and that therefore Christians have a duty to rebel against earthly lords who do not acknowledge that and to repudiate laws that seem to repudiate the law of God. So Karlstadt writes, where Christians rule, there they should consider no government, but rather freely on their own, hew down and throw down what is contrary to God. So Karlstadt is more similar to, let's say, what a Muslim theologian of the same period, an Islamic theologian of the 16th century would have said, which is, why would you distinguish between the world of the state and the world of the spirit, as it were? I mean, obviously, if you believe a religion, then you think it should influence
路德拒绝了这一点，即上帝的法律比世俗法律更重要，因此基督徒有义务反抗那些不承认这一点的世俗领主，并抵制那些似乎抵制上帝法律的法律。所以卡尔施塔特写道：在基督徒统治的地方，他们不应考虑任何政府，而应自由地、凭自己的意愿砍倒和推翻那些违背上帝的东西。所以卡尔施塔特更类似于，比如说，同一时期的穆斯林神学家，16世纪的伊斯兰神学家会说的话，那就是，你为什么要区分国家的世界和精神的世界呢？我的意思是，显然，如果你相信一种宗教，那么你认为它应该影响
everything and you shouldn't sort of erect an artificial boundary between the religious and the secular. Well, the difference between Latin Christendom and the world of Islam is that Latin Christendom has this concept of there being rival dimensions of what will become religion and the secular. And the process by which religion and the secular come to be enshrined is absolutely influenced by this period. And Luther, again, plays a key role in it. So Luther is forced by Karl Schlatt's arguments to kind of try and refine and work out exactly what he thinks. And so he says that there is Christian freedom, but it exists purely in the spiritual dimension. So in the dimension of what is coming to be called religion. So against the backdrop of the Peasants' War, he says that there
一切，你不应该在宗教和世俗之间建立人为的界限。嗯，拉丁基督教世界和伊斯兰世界之间的区别在于，拉丁基督教有这种概念，即存在着将成为宗教和世俗的竞争维度。而宗教和世俗被确立的过程绝对受到这一时期的影响。而路德，再次，在其中扮演了关键角色。所以路德被迫通过卡尔施塔特的论点来尝试提炼和弄清楚他到底在想什么。所以他说存在基督徒的自由，但它纯粹存在于精神维度。所以，在正在被称为宗教的维度中。因此，在农民战争的背景下，他说
are two kingdoms, one the kingdom of God, the other the kingdom of the world. And this really is where our notion of religion as something that is simultaneously private and personal to an individual, and secondly, something that you choose. So I think that is kind of hardwired into the meaning of religion in English. You say, what religion are you? What kind of confessional group do you belong to? And what do you personally believe? And that's an understanding of it that had not existed before. And so that's why I think the understanding of religion in English and in the languages
有两个王国，一个是上帝的王国，另一个是世界的王国。这确实是我们关于宗教的概念，即宗教既是私人的、个人的，又是你选择的东西。所以我认为这已经硬编码在英语中“宗教”的含义里了。你说，你信什么宗教？你属于哪种忏悔团体？你个人相信什么？这是一种以前不存在的理解。所以这就是为什么我认为英语和其他新教欧洲国家语言中对宗教的理解，是一种非常新教的理解，它诞生于这一时期。这并不意味着路德钦佩王子。基本上，他在说，基督徒在他的灵魂中有自由。因此，世俗权力在做什么并不重要。他鄙视王子。他说他们通常是地球上最大的傻瓜或最坏的无赖。但他说，青蛙需要鹳。对。但那可能是很多即使在2020年代听这个的人也会反对的东西。他们会说，不，如果你相信某件事，你应该改变世界。我的意思是，学校告诉他们的孩子，去改变世界。
of other Protestant European countries, it's a very Protestant understanding, and it is born from this period. This doesn't mean that Luther admires the princes. Basically, he's saying, a Christian has freedom in his soul. It doesn't therefore matter what the secular powers are doing. He despises princes. He says that they're generally the biggest fools or the worst scoundrels on earth. But he says, frogs need stalks. Right. But that is something that maybe a lot of people even listening to this right now in the 2020s would object to. They would say, no, if you believe in something, you should change the world. I mean, schools tell their kids, go and change the world.
如果你相信一个事业，那么你不仅仅是说，好吧，世界就是这样，你知道，世俗统治者就是这样。对。但同样，人们会说宗教不应该干涉。你知道，穆斯林不应该试图把他们的信仰强加给整个社会，他们应该把它当作私人的东西，或者基督徒也一样。教会和国家应该分开。教会和国家应该分开。这在整个拉丁基督教的历史中有着非常非常深厚的根源，但它在英国或美国或英语世界中通过这个过程得到了加强和提炼。但我认为这在英语世界中对我们来说不太清楚，因为当然我们不是直接从路德那里得到的。所以这个想法，即本质上你可以赶走教皇，作为王子，对你统治的地方的整个结构负责，
If you believe in a cause, then you don't just say, well, the world is as it is, you know, secular rulers are as they are. Right. But again, people will say religion shouldn't interfere. You know, Muslims shouldn't try and impose their beliefs on society as a whole, that they should treat it as something private or indeed Christians. Church and state should be separate. Church and state should be separate. And this has very, very deep roots in the entire history of Latin Christendom, but it's one that is sharpened and refined, say in Britain or America or the kind of English speaking world by this process. But I think that this is less clear to us in the English speaking world because of course we do not get it directly from Luther. So the idea that essentially you can kick out the Pope and as a prince take responsibility for
显然有很大的吸引力，特别是对德国的王子们来说。所以其中最重要的一位是黑森的统治者菲利普。他在沃尔姆斯见过路德并受到启发，并在1525年被梅兰希通完全转化。在1530年代，路德宗开始扎根，特别是在斯堪的纳维亚和波罗的海地区。直到今天，它仍然是斯堪的纳维亚基督教的主要形式。但正如我所说，传到英国和苏格兰并从那里传到美国的宗教改革来自瑞士，并受到卡尔施塔特的影响。卡洛斯·艾尔在他的《宗教改革》一书中对此有一段精彩的评论。
the whole fabric of the place that you're ruling obviously has great appeal, particularly for princes in Germany. So the most significant of these is the ruler of Hesse, Philip. He'd met and been inspired by Luther at Worms and he'd been fully converted by Melanchthon in 1525. And over the course of the 1530s, Lutheranism starts to bed down, particularly in Scandinavia and in the Baltic. And it remains the dominant form of Christianity in Scandinavia to this day. But as I said, the Reformation that comes to England and Scotland and from there to America comes from Switzerland and is influenced by Karlstadt. And there's this brilliant comment on this by Carlos Eyre in his book Reformations.
当英国国王查理一世于1649年1月30日登上断头台被清教徒革命者斩首时，他可能不知道卡尔施塔特的精神引导了他刽子手的手。对。关于瑞士的角度，所以瑞士人在1520年代一直在进行他们自己的一种平行宗教改革，不是吗？
When King Charles I of England mounted the scaffold on the 30th of January 1649 to be beheaded by Puritan revolutionaries, he probably did not know that the spirit of Karlstadt guided his executioner's hand. Right. So just on the Swiss angle, so the Swiss have been having their own kind of parallel reformation, haven't they, in the 1520s?
一个叫胡尔德里希·茨温利的人。他们和香肠之间有一些事情。是的，他们干涉香肠。总之，瑞士，我想它发生在瑞士，就像在德国，在神圣罗马帝国一样，
A guy called Huldrych Zwingli. There's some sort of business with them interfering with sausages. Yeah, they interfere with sausages. And anyway, Switzerland, I guess it happens in Switzerland, like in Germany, in the Holy Roman Empire,
因为瑞士非常碎片化，所有独立的州。所以在这个人们已经自治的世界里，你可以看出为什么异端思想、独立思想、你与上帝个人交流的思想，为什么它们会繁荣。当然，在瑞士，中央权威比在德国更弱。所以宗教改革可以走得更远。这些人，所以苏黎世到1524年，它禁止了教堂里的音乐，禁止了图像，这非常卡尔施塔特。他们在1525年禁止了弥撒。所以汤姆，有趣的是，考虑到我们认为英国国教是天主教和新教之间的一种中间道路，但英国国教，有趣的是，考虑到我们认为英国国教是天主教和新教之间的一种中间道路，但英国国教，例如，英国的新教，你说比路德宗更瑞士化。是的，绝对。正是在这一时期，任何关于路德派和我们称之为瑞士形式的新教之间和解的前景都被拒绝了。
because Switzerland is very fragmented, all its independent canthons. And so in that world where people are kind of already self-governing, you can see why heretical ideas, ideas of independence, of you in personal communion with God, why they would prosper. And of course, in Switzerland, central authority is even weaker than in Germany. So the Reformation can go even further. And these are people, so Zurich by 1524, it's banned music in churches, it's banned images, which is very Kallstadt. They banned the mass in 1525. And so Tom, funnily enough, given that we think of the Church of England as a kind of middle way between Catholic and Protestant, but the Church of England, for enough, given that we think of the Church of England as a kind of middle way between Catholic and Protestant, but the Church of England, for example, Protestantism in England, you're saying is more Swiss than Lutheran. Yes, absolutely. And it's in this period that any prospect of kind of reconciliation between the Lutheran and let's call them the Swiss forms of Protestantism are rejected.
主要是路德，必须说，因为当然，这是你在上一集中指出的伟大点。事实上，圣经和圣经的启示并不是不言自明的，这就是问题所在。它开启了福音派、改革者可以走的各种潜在道路，路德认为这很可怕。卡尔施塔特走了一条，但当然，另一个人走了一条路德认为很可怕的路。卡尔施塔特走了一条。但当然，另一个人走了一条路德不想走的路，就是我们在这一集开头提到的那个人，托马斯·闵采尔。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，看看他发生了什么。好的，非常好。汤姆，我喜欢路德，当他表现不好的时候。
Chiefly by Luther, it has to be said, because, of course, this is the great point that you pointed to in the previous episode. The fact that actually scripture and the illumination of scripture is not self-evident and this is the problem. And it opens up all kinds of potential roads that evangelicals, reformers can go down that Luther thinks is terrible. And Karlstadt has gone down one, but of course, the other person who takes a road that Luther thinks is terrible. And Karlstadt has gone down one. But of course, the other person who takes a road that Luther does not want to tread is the guy that we began this episode with, Thomas Munzer. And I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, look at what happens to him. Okay, very good. I liked Luther, Tom, when he was behaving badly,
不得不说，这主要是路德的观点，因为这当然就是你在上一集中指出的重要一点。事实上，圣经及其启示并非不言自明，这就是问题所在。这开启了福音派和改革者可能走上的各种潜在道路，而路德认为这些道路非常糟糕。卡尔施塔特已经走上了一条，但当然，另一个人走的路也是路德认为非常糟糕的。卡尔施塔特已经走上了一条。但当然，另一个人走的路也是路德不想涉足的，那就是我们在本集开头提到的那个人，托马斯·闵采尔。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，看看他发生了什么。好的，非常好。汤姆，我喜欢路德表现不佳的时候。
when he was becoming more conservative and he was being really horrible to Karlstadt. But then he reminded me of his stupidity on this question of the interpretation of scripture and he's gone down in my estimation once again. Return after the second half to see if Luther can recover, but more excitingly, this extraordinary man Munzer and what he gets up to. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
当他变得越来越保守，对卡尔施塔特表现得非常恶劣时。但随后他在这本经文解读问题上的愚蠢表现又提醒了我，他在我心中的评价再次下降。下半场回来后，看看路德能否挽回形象，更令人兴奋的是，这位非凡的人物闵采尔以及他的所作所为。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Ah, but how splendid it is when the Spirit of God teaches us and more, helps us understand first this passage, then that one. God be praised, revealing to me the real authentic light shining forth. That was an archive recording of Argula von Grumbach, who is a Bavarian noblewoman. And she'd read Luther's translation of the New Testament. And she had been awakened, Tom.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。啊，当上帝的灵教导我们，并帮助我们理解这段经文，然后是那段经文时，那是多么美妙啊。赞美上帝，向我揭示了闪耀出的真实而纯正的光芒。那是一段阿古拉·冯·格伦巴赫的档案录音，她是一位巴伐利亚贵族女性。她读过路德翻译的《新约》。汤姆，她已经被唤醒了。
She had been enlightened by that light shining forth. So he ended the first half by talking about this apparent contradiction or this slight hole in his argument, which is he basically says, it's all in the Bible. You just look in the Bible and everything is absolutely clear. You will receive the enlightenment that you seek. And obviously lots of his followers think, oh, brilliant. We'll read his translation of the New Testament and then we will be enlightened. But Tom, by the mid 1520s, there are lots of people on there who used to be great fans of Martin Luther and now think, actually, you know, I'm not enlightened at all from his stuff. He's actually taken a terrible wrong turn. Yeah. And they're saying, you know, this is a guy who's preached freedom.
她被那道闪耀的光芒所启迪。所以他在上半场结束时谈到了这个明显的矛盾，或者说他论点中的这个小漏洞，即他基本上说，一切都在圣经里。你只要看圣经，一切都绝对清晰。你会得到你所寻求的启迪。显然，他的许多追随者认为，哦，太棒了。我们将阅读他翻译的《新约》，然后我们就会得到启迪。但是汤姆，到了1520年代中期，有很多人曾经是马丁·路德的忠实粉丝，现在却认为，实际上，你知道，我从他的东西里根本没有得到任何启迪。他实际上走上了一条极其错误的道路。是的。他们说，你知道，这是一个宣扬自由的人。
So why is he dragging his feet over the freedom of peasants? Why shouldn't they be freed from serfdom? He's opposed the Pope. He's opposed the emperor. Why is he not opposing the princes? And why, when you have a rebellion of the poor and the oppressed, is he siding with the rich? And these are questions that Karlstadt, who we talked about in the first half, had been figure, and indeed an even more radical figure, and that, Dominic, is Thomas Munzer. You began the episode by reading out the long list of insults that he had been directing at Luther, and who in 1524 and 1525 absolutely takes the side of the peasants in a way that Luther is not. So his background, he's a youthful admirer of Luther. He'd actually spent time at Wittenberg at around the time that
那么他为什么要拖延农民的自由呢？他们为什么不应该从农奴制中解放出来？他反对教皇。他反对皇帝。为什么他不反对诸侯？为什么当穷人和被压迫者发生叛乱时，他却站在富人一边？这些就是我们在上半场讨论过的卡尔施塔特所提出的问题，他是一个重要人物，而另一个更激进的人物，多米尼克，就是托马斯·闵采尔。你以宣读他针对路德的一长串侮辱性言论开始了这一集，他在1524年和1525年以一种路德所没有的方式绝对站在了农民一边。关于他的背景，他是路德年轻时的崇拜者。他实际上在路德张贴《九十五条论纲》前后在维滕贝格待过一段时间。
Luther is posting his theses. And this inspires him. And by 1520, very modestly, he is describing himself as he who fights for truth in the world. Oh, he's a be kind person. That would absolutely be his hashtag, I think. And he's also into the idea that you read the Bible and it provides a blueprint for what you should do. So he argues that the early church had held all things in common. So therefore, there should be communism. That God had slain idolaters, so he cites the example of the priests of Baal who had been slain by Elijah. Therefore, all Catholic priests and monks should be put to the sword. And you talked about the apocalyptic
这激励了他。到了1520年，他非常谦虚地将自己描述为“在世界上为真理而战的人”。哦，他是个善良的人。我想那绝对会是他的标签。他还沉迷于这样一种想法：阅读圣经可以为你应该做的事情提供蓝图。因此，他认为早期教会实行凡物公用。所以，应该有共产主义。上帝曾杀戮偶像崇拜者，所以他引用了以利亚杀戮巴力祭司的例子。因此，所有天主教神父和修士都应该被处死。你谈到了那种末日
mood. Munzer loves the book of Revelation, which describes the four horsemen of the apocalypse, coming of Christ and all that kind of thing. And so Munzer says, well, this is approaching, therefore all earthly authorities must be overthrown. And like Karlstadt, he argues that you can only properly understand scripture if the Spirit has come upon you. And Munzer proclaims not only that the Spirit has come upon him, but that he is a God-appointed prophet and that it is his duty to proclaim to the Christian people the end of days. And so he sums this up in kind of very cheery tones. The elect must clash with the damned, he writes, and the power of the damned must yield before that of the elect. The time of the harvest is at hand.
情绪。闵采尔热爱《启示录》，书中描述了末日的四骑士、基督的降临等等。所以闵采尔说，好吧，这一切即将来临，因此所有世俗权威都必须被推翻。像卡尔施塔特一样，他认为只有当圣灵降临在你身上时，你才能正确理解经文。闵采尔不仅宣称圣灵降临在他身上，还宣称自己是上帝指定的先知，他的职责是向基督徒宣告末日的到来。他用非常欢快的语调总结了这一点。他写道，选民必须与被诅咒者发生冲突，被诅咒者的力量必须在选民面前屈服。收获的季节即将来临。
I have made my sickle sharp. So, Tom, the sickle, that's a lovely link because actually in the German Democratic Republic in East Germany, in schools, they would really big up Munzer as a sort of proto-Bolshevik. They would say Munzer is a Marxist avant la lettre. He's a spokesman for the downtrodden proletariat. All of his stuff really is just... He's like a Lenin. Yeah. He appears on the bank notes of the East German Republic. Yeah. I'm guessing you're going to say they have misappropriated Munzer. No, not at all.
我已经磨快了我的镰刀。所以，汤姆，“镰刀”是一个很好的联系，因为实际上在东德的德意志民主共和国，学校里会把闵采尔捧为某种原始布尔什维克。他们会说闵采尔是“先于列宁的马克思主义者”。他是受压迫无产阶级的代言人。他所有的东西其实都只是……他就像列宁。是的。他出现在东德的钞票上。是的。我猜你会说他们挪用了闵采尔。不，一点也不。
Oh, you don't think that? No, I think absolutely. That kind of apocalyptic sense that the rich are being cast down and that the poor are being raised up. I mean, I think, you know, as you know, I completely think that's Christian. It's just, it's been so secularized that all traces of God in the Bible have gone, but it's clear where it derives from. And in a sense, Luther's horror at it is a kind of foretaste of the horror of people who don't want to be part of a communist order. And so again, in his reaction, as in his revolutionary qualities, he is the great primal figure in modern European history. Yeah, exactly. My revolution, but not your revolution. The revolution should stop now. Absolutely. Yeah. So he's very agitated about this. So July 1524, by which point the Peasants' War is spreading very fast across Germany, he writes a pamphlet,
哦，你不这么认为吗？不，我绝对认为。那种富人被推翻、穷人被提升的末日感。我的意思是，我认为，如你所知，我完全认为那是基督教的。它只是被世俗化了，以至于上帝在圣经中的所有痕迹都消失了，但它源于何处是很清楚的。在某种意义上，路德对此的恐惧是对那些不想成为共产主义秩序一部分的人的恐惧的预演。因此，在这一反应中，正如在他的革命品质中一样，他是现代欧洲历史上伟大的原始人物。是的，正是如此。我的革命，但不是你的革命。革命现在应该停止了。绝对是。是的。所以他对此非常焦虑。所以1524年7月，当时农民战争在德国蔓延得非常快，他写了一本小册子，
which he calls Letter to the Princes of Saxony Concerning the Rebellious Spirit. And he doesn't name either Karlstadt or Munzer, but he brackets them together and urges the princes to take action against them and against their followers. And this is a very well-timed appeal because at the same time it comes out, Frederick the Elector of Saxony, his younger brother and heir presumptive, John, he's called, who is a very, very committed admirer of Luther, finds himself in the place where Munzer has his church. And Munzer comes and preaches. And it's fair to say that the homily he gives the
他称之为《致萨克森诸侯关于叛乱精神的信》。他没有点名卡尔施塔特或闵采尔，但他把他们归为一类，并敦促诸侯对他们及其追随者采取行动。这是一个时机非常好的呼吁，因为与此同时，萨克森选侯弗里德里希的弟弟兼推定继承人约翰，他是一个非常非常坚定的路德崇拜者，发现自己身处闵采尔拥有教堂的地方。闵采尔来了并进行了布道。公平地说，他给出的讲道
sermon is kind of ill-advised yeah this guy carlos air describes it as one of the most inappropriate and impolitic homilies of all time yeah so munzer announces to the to the duke and the duke has his son with him as well that he's a prophet urges the du Duke and his son to slaughter the godless, warns them that if they do not, then God will take their swords from them, and inevitably engages in some excrement-based ranting. Rejoice, you true friends of God, that the enemies of the cross have beshat their courage into their trousers. What is it with these guys? What's going on with them? So this doesn't go down well. The Saxon princes expel Munzer from his holding. Munzer blames Luther for this. And this is why he is writing the abusive pamphlet in November, in which he calls Luther soft living flesh. Because by this point, Luther has really become quite fat.
布道有点欠考虑。是的，这个叫卡洛斯·艾尔的人将其描述为有史以来最不恰当、最不明智的讲道之一。是的，所以闵采尔向公爵宣布，公爵还带着他的儿子，说他是一位先知，敦促公爵和他的儿子屠杀那些不敬神的人，警告他们如果不这样做，上帝就会夺走他们的剑，并且不可避免地进行了一些基于排泄物的谩骂。欢呼吧，你们这些上帝的真朋友，十字架的敌人已经把他们的勇气拉进裤子里了。这些人到底怎么了？他们怎么回事？所以这并没有产生好的效果。萨克森诸侯将闵采尔驱逐出他的领地。闵采尔因此责怪路德。这就是为什么他在11月写了那本辱骂性的小册子，他在其中称路德为“生活安逸的肉体”。因为到这个时候，路德确实变得相当胖了。
So that very thin and scrawny monk. Yeah. Fine dining, courtesy of Frederick as protector, right? luther has really become quite fat so that very thin and scrawny monk yeah fine dining courtesy of uh frederick is protector right capons quails yeah but also it's an expression of his theology if we're all damned yeah let's crack on no point dieting crack on yeah you know i'm elect i can eat what i like munster thinks this is terrible i I mean, it's kind of interesting. Munster, despite being radical in so many ways, does see Luther's bulk as embodying a kind of moral turpitude. And so he has all these weird, sinister fantasies about slow cooking Luther. What? He's going to eat Luther? No, he's going to serve him to the devil.
所以那个非常瘦弱的修士。是的。弗里德里希作为保护者提供的精致餐饮，对吧？路德确实变得相当胖了，所以那个非常瘦弱的修士，是的，弗里德里希作为保护者提供的精致餐饮，对吧？阉鸡、鹌鹑，是的。但这也是他神学的一种表达。如果我们都被诅咒了，是的，让我们继续吧，没必要节食，继续吧。你知道，我是选民，我可以吃我想吃的。闵采尔认为这太可怕了。我的意思是，这很有趣。闵采尔尽管在许多方面都很激进，但他确实将路德的肥胖视为一种道德堕落的体现。所以他有所有这些奇怪、阴险的关于慢炖路德的幻想。什么？他要吃掉路德？不，他要用他来侍奉魔鬼。
Oh, right. And says that Luther's so fat that he'd have to cook him for hours and hours in an oven. I mean, very, very weird. Luther has become Chris Christie, the erstwhile Republican presidential hopeful. Yeah. He's certainly bulking out in that way. Yeah. And he's saying not only has Luther become fat, but he's become everything that he'd previously hated, that he's become a Pope. We've said that he calls him a monk, calls him ambassador of the devil, and very, very painfully for Luther, accuses him of misunderstanding scripture. Says that he's a man who has made a mockery and an utterly useless babble out of the divine word, which of course is the precise opposite of what Luther thinks.
哦，对了。并说路德太胖了，他得在烤箱里煮他好几个小时。我的意思是，非常非常奇怪。路德已经变成了克里斯·克里斯蒂，那位曾经的共和党总统候选人。是的。他确实在那方面变得臃肿了。是的。他说路德不仅变胖了，而且变成了他以前所憎恨的一切，他变成了一个教皇。我们说过他称他为修士，称他为魔鬼的使者，而且对路德来说非常非常痛苦的是，指责他误解了经文。说他是一个把神圣的话语变成嘲弄和完全无用的胡言乱语的人，这当然与路德的想法完全相反。
And Munzer basically is casting Wittenberg as a kind of parallel of Rome. What is it? Two cheeks of the same arse is the phrase. Right. I mean, it's not what that depicts, but we can go with that phrase if you like. But it's very, very Munzer friendly, isn't it? I mean, I can absolutely imagine that he would have said that. It's very Munzer friendly. Yeah. And so it's because of this, the fact that you have now Rome and Wittenberg,
闵采尔基本上把维滕贝格描绘成罗马的某种平行物。是什么？“同一个屁股的两瓣”是这句话。对。我的意思是，这不是那幅画所描绘的，但如果你喜欢，我们可以用那句话。但这非常非常符合闵采尔的风格，不是吗？我的意思是，我绝对可以想象他会那样说。这非常符合闵采尔的风格。是的。所以正是因为这个，因为你现在有了罗马和维滕贝格，
and both of them are Babylon, that this is why he thinks that the end times are approaching. And it's why once he's been expelled by the Dukes of Saxony, he goes to Mulhausen. and both of them are Babylon, that this is why he thinks that the end times are approaching. And it's why once he's been expelled by the Dukes of Saxony, he goes to Mulhausen and he kind of says, you know, you are the elect. This is why he does his great white flag with his rainbow and recruits his devout Christians to follow him. And it's a holy war. And how he comes in May 1525 to be marching against the local princes towards the town of Frankenhausen. So Tom, I was just thinking, how could they have let this get to this crazy situation where this bloke, you know, ranting and raving, has raised an army? And actually you said he goes to Mühlhausen in February 1525.
而且它们都是巴比伦，这就是为什么他认为末日即将来临。这就是为什么一旦他被萨克森公爵驱逐，他就去了米尔豪森。而且它们都是巴比伦，这就是为什么他认为末日即将来临。这就是为什么一旦他被萨克森公爵驱逐，他就去了米尔豪森，他基本上说，你知道，你们是选民。这就是为什么他制作了他那面带有彩虹的大白旗，并招募他虔诚的基督徒追随他。这是一场圣战。以及他如何在1525年5月开始向当地诸侯进军，前往弗兰肯豪森镇。所以汤姆，我刚才在想，他们怎么能让事情发展到这种疯狂的地步，这个家伙，你知道，咆哮着，竟然组建了一支军队？而且你确实说过他在1525年2月去了米尔豪森。
And there's an obvious reason why it's got to this point, because the emperor in February 1525 is off in Italy fighting a gigantic battle against the French, the Battle of Pavia, where he captures the French king. So the emperor, Charles V, is completely distracted. Right. He's off fighting this titanic war against the French. And in his backyard, you know, it's just all completely falling apart. Right. And that's why Luther is still alive. If Charles had been undistracted by all his other responsibilities as king of Spain and invading Italy and worrying about the Turks and so on, then he could have launched a campaign,
事情发展到这一步有一个明显的原因，因为1525年2月的皇帝正在意大利与法国人进行一场巨大的战斗，即帕维亚战役，他在那里俘虏了法国国王。所以皇帝查理五世完全分心了。对。他正忙着与法国人进行这场泰坦尼克式的战争。而在他的后院，你知道，一切都完全崩溃了。对。这就是为什么路德还活着。如果查理没有被他作为西班牙国王、入侵意大利、担心土耳其人等等的所有其他责任所分心，那么他本可以发动一场战役，
invaded Wittenberg, killed Luther, wiped the Reformation out. But he doesn't because he has so many distractions. And that means that it's down to the local princes to sort it out. And when Munzer hears who is leading the princely armies against him, it confirms him in all his contempt and hatred for the princes as representatives of Antichrist, because we mentioned how one of the princes is the Catholic brother of Frederick, the Elector of Saxony. George. Georg. Yeah. But the other one, Dominic, is Philip of Hesse, who has recently been converted by Philip Melanchthon to Lutheranism. So there they are. It's a Catholic and a Lutheran prince facing him. of the battle. Munzer goes all in. His men are angels of light. The enemies are the devil. He rides around the camp, telling them to trust in God, promising them that the shot of their
入侵维滕贝格，杀死路德，消灭宗教改革。但他没有，因为他有太多的分心。这意味着只能由当地诸侯来解决。当闵采尔听到是谁在率领诸侯军队对抗他时，这证实了他对诸侯作为反基督代表的所有蔑视和仇恨，因为我们提到过其中一位诸侯是萨克森选侯弗里德里希的天主教兄弟。乔治。格奥尔格。是的。但另一个，多米尼克，是黑森的菲利普，他最近被菲利普·梅兰希通改宗为路德宗。所以他们就在那里。这是一个天主教和路德宗的诸侯在面对他。战斗的。闵采尔全力以赴。他的人是光明的天使。敌人是魔鬼。他在营地里骑马，告诉他们要相信上帝，向他们保证他们敌人的射击
enemies will have no power to harm them. And Dominic, this does not turn out to be the case. I mean, he's got a big army, Tom. 8,000 people or so. I mean, this is not a punch up in a back alley kind of thing. But it kind of is, because the word of God does not really help them because they've only got bill hooks and whatever. And they're against trained men who have been raised to fight and kill. They just get slaughtered. And pretty much all of the people in Frankhausen are either slaughtered or taken prisoner. And when some of the women go to the princes after the battle, I mean, calling it a battle is excessive, after the massacre and say, you know, could we have our men who are captive back? The princes say, okay, you can, provided that you put to death two of the rebel priests who we've captured. It's your responsibility to kill them. And I think it's a
将无力伤害他们。多米尼克，事实并非如此。我的意思是，他有一支庞大的军队，汤姆。大约8000人。我的意思是，这可不是小巷里的斗殴。但这确实有点像，因为上帝的话语并没有真正帮助他们，因为他们只有长柄钩刀之类的东西。而他们面对的是受过训练、被培养来战斗和杀戮的人。他们只是被屠杀了。弗兰肯豪森几乎所有的人要么被屠杀，要么被俘虏。当一些妇女在战斗后去找诸侯时，我的意思是，称之为战斗是夸张的，在屠杀之后，说，你知道，我们能要回我们被俘的男人吗？诸侯说，好吧，你们可以，前提是你们处死我们俘虏的两名叛军神父。杀死他们是你们的责任。我认为这是一个
measure of the kind of the horror and the madness of the times that the women reach for cudgels and start smacking the priests, smashing their bones, cracking their skulls. And it is said that they keep smashing and beating them for half an hour after they've died. Oh, my word. So they're just a kind of bloody pulp. So, Tom, do you want a brilliant fact about the Battle of Frankenhausen? Yeah, please. Great. So the Battle of Frankenhausen is the subject of the world's largest painting is it and this was commissioned by our old friends
衡量那个时代恐怖和疯狂的尺度，妇女们伸手去拿棍棒，开始猛击神父，打碎他们的骨头，敲碎他们的头骨。据说在他们死后，她们又继续猛击和殴打他们半个小时。哦，天哪。所以他们只是一堆血肉模糊的东西。所以，汤姆，你想要一个关于弗兰肯豪森战役的精彩事实吗？是的，请。太棒了。所以弗兰肯豪森战役是世界上最大的画作的主题，是吗？这是由我们的老朋友
the leaders of east germany in the late 1970s it is in bad frankenhausen in the panorama museum and it shows the battle of frankenhaus, but can you guess what they would call it? The Rising of the Proletariat against the evil capitalists or something. Pretty good. It's actually called the Early Bourgeois Revolution in Germany. Brilliant. And I'll tell you how big it is.
东德领导人在1970年代末委托创作的。它位于巴特弗兰肯豪森的全景博物馆中，展示了弗兰肯豪森战役，但你能猜出他们会称它为什么吗？“无产阶级反抗邪恶资本家的起义”之类的。相当不错。它实际上被称为“德国早期资产阶级革命”。太棒了。我告诉你它有多大。
It is 46 feet by 404 feet. Wow, that is big. So it's a bloody big painting. And is it kind of like Where's Wally? Can you see where Munster is? Because Munster is found hiding in an attic after the battle. It's got 3,000 people. So it must have Munster.
它是46英尺乘404英尺。哇，那太大了。所以这是一幅血腥的大画。它有点像《威利在哪里》吗？你能看到闵采尔在哪里吗？因为闵采尔是在战斗后被发现躲在阁楼里的。它有3000个人。所以它一定有闵采尔。
Yeah, he must be there somewhere. Yeah. So he gets found hiding in an attic. He gets dragged out. He says he's had nothing to do with it. He's completely innocent. And then they look through his bag and they find basically, I am Thomas Munster, you know, all over it.. He gets dragged in front of Duke George of Saxony.
是的，他一定在某个地方。是的。所以他被发现躲在阁楼里。他被拖了出来。他说他与此无关。他是完全无辜的。然后他们搜查了他的包，发现基本上，我就是托马斯·闵采尔，你知道，到处都是。他被拖到萨克森公爵乔治面前。
Munster is unapologetic. He uses the incorrectly respectful form of you to George. Oh, he misuses him. He misclasses him again. He justifies the war. He's endlessly quoting the Bible. The Duke puts him to torture. There are stories that he recounts his views, but there's no evidence for this whatsoever in his public statements after this. He remains completely defiant. And he's handed over to the Count of Mansfeld. And Mansfeld, Dominic, you may remember, is the place where Luther had grown up. And the Count of Mansfeld takes Munzer back to Mühlhausen, where he had proclaimed that he was the prophet of the end times. He's beheaded outside its walls,
闵采尔毫不悔改。他用不正确的尊称“你”来称呼乔治。哦，他误用了他。他再次对他进行了错误的分类。他为战争辩护。他不断地引用圣经。公爵对他施以酷刑。有故事说他撤回了自己的观点，但在他此后的公开声明中没有任何证据支持这一点。他仍然完全蔑视。他被移交给了曼斯费尔德伯爵。多米尼克，你可能记得，曼斯费尔德是路德长大的地方。曼斯费尔德伯爵把闵采尔带回了米尔豪森，他在那里宣称自己是末日的先知。他在城墙外被斩首，
and his head is put on a spike, and his body is put on public display to serve as a warning and a terror. So that thing about serving as a warning and a terror, there are some historians, aren't there, who say that effectively, Munster was not as important as we now think, and that Luther and Luther's allies inflated him. They deliberately exaggerated his importance because they wanted to create a bogeyman and to frighten people away from radicalism and back towards conservatism. In other words, they were doing exactly the same as what people did in 1650s England with, let's say, the ranters, who maybe didn't even exist, and that actually
他的头被插在长矛上，他的身体被公开展示，以作为警告和恐怖。所以关于作为警告和恐怖的那件事，有一些历史学家，不是吗，他们说实际上，闵采尔并不像我们现在认为的那么重要，路德和路德的盟友夸大了他。他们故意夸大了他的重要性，因为他们想制造一个妖怪，把人们从激进主义中吓跑，回到保守主义。换句话说，他们所做的和1650年代英国人对待，比如说，那些可能根本不存在的“狂乱者”所做的事情完全一样，而实际上
Munster was a more marginal and bonkers figure. Munster is definitely a marginal figure. I mean, the Peasants' War does not happen because of Munster. Munster is piggybacking onto the Peasants' Rebellion. But I think he does matter because he is a foretaste of the radicalism that you're talking about. So the belief that you can only understand scripture if you are possessed by the Spirit. I mean, this is fundamental to Baptists and Quakers and Anabaptists and all these kind of people who will be emerging from this forging ground. So in terms of the war itself, Munzer is not important. But as a kind of portent of what will come, I think he is important. And you're right, that Luther does focus on him. And just as Munzer had seen the hand of the devil in the victory of
闵采尔是一个更边缘和疯狂的人物。闵采尔绝对是一个边缘人物。我的意思是，农民战争并不是因为闵采尔而发生的。闵采尔是在搭农民起义的便车。但我认为他确实很重要，因为他是你所谈论的激进主义的预演。所以那种认为只有当你被圣灵附体时才能理解经文的信念。我的意思是，这对于浸信会、贵格会、再洗礼派以及所有这些将从这片锻造地中涌现出来的人来说是根本性的。所以就战争本身而言，闵采尔并不重要。但作为一种未来事物的预兆，我认为他很重要。你是对的，路德确实关注他。正如闵采尔在胜利中看到了魔鬼的手一样
the princes, Luther sees the hand of the devil in the entire conflict. It's not just the destruction. You have 100,000 people slaughtered, terrible bloodletting. It's also that Luther is being blamed for this bloodshed by lots of his enemies. Here is Johan Cocleus, the guy who had argued with him at Worms and the subject of all those very abusive pictures. Cocleus wrote, there were many peasants slain in the uprising, many fanatics banished, many false prophets hanged, burned, drowned, or beheaded, who perhaps would still live as good, obedient Christians had he never written. And I think it's a mark of how unsettling this charge is to Luther, as well as of his complete egocentrism,
诸侯们，路德在整个冲突中看到了魔鬼的手。这不仅仅是破坏。你有10万人被屠杀，可怕的流血事件。这也是路德因为这场流血事件而受到许多敌人的指责。这是约翰·科克莱乌斯，那个在沃尔姆斯与他争论的人，也是所有那些非常辱骂性图片的主题。科克莱乌斯写道，起义中有许多农民被杀，许多狂热分子被放逐，许多假先知被绞死、烧死、淹死或斩首，如果他从未写作，他们也许仍然会作为善良、顺从的基督徒活着。我认为这标志着这一指控对路德有多么令人不安，以及他完全的自我中心，
that he sees the peasants' war as a direct attempt by the devil to destroy him. It's all about me. It really is all about Luther. So his response to this is twofold. The first is very personal. The second is much more public. So the first thing he does, Munzer has been accusing him of being a monk, of being a Pope and so on. So he responds to this in the most provocative way that he can. So on the 13th of June, 1525, a month after the death of Munzer, Luther marries a nun. And this is a woman called Katharina von Bora, who is 26. So he's not doing a Karlstadt. How old is he?
他认为农民战争是魔鬼直接试图摧毁他。这完全是关于我。这确实完全是关于路德。所以他对这一点的反应是双重的。第一是极其个人的。第二是更加公开的。所以他做的第一件事，闵采尔一直指责他是一个修士，是一个教皇等等。所以他以他能做到的最挑衅的方式回应了这一点。所以1525年6月13日，在闵采尔死后一个月，路德娶了一位修女。这是一个叫卡塔琳娜·冯·博拉的女人，她26岁。所以他没有做卡尔施塔特做的事。他多大了？
He's in his early forties by this point. Okay. So he's done well for himself, but he hasn't completely embarrassed himself. Exactly. Hasn't gone the full Leo. So he'd actually played a part in helping her to escape from her convent. She'd read him and become an evangelical, wanted to leave the nunnery that she'd been in. And Luther arranges for her to escape in a wagon carrying barrels of herring. And she seems great. You know, she's kind of funny, smart, good for Luther, I think. Right.
到这个时候他已经四十出头了。好吧。所以他做得很好，但他并没有完全让自己难堪。正是如此。没有完全变成利奥。所以他实际上在帮助她从修道院逃跑中发挥了作用。她读过他的书并成为了一名福音派信徒，想离开她所在的修女院。路德安排她藏在装满鲱鱼桶的马车里逃走。她看起来很棒。你知道，她很有趣，聪明，我认为对路德很好。对。
And Luther claimed that he had married her to please his father, annoy the Pope, amuse the angels and make the devil weep. But he is happy with her. Obviously, I mean, he's a massive patriarch. He's in no way a feminist dad, I think it would be fair to say. But they get on well. She gives him six children. She helps to fatten him up even more. Right.
路德声称他娶她是取悦他的父亲，惹恼教皇，逗乐天使，让魔鬼哭泣。但他对她很满意。显然，我的意思是，他是一个巨大的父权制者。我认为公平地说，他绝不是一个女权主义父亲。但他们相处得很好。她为他生了六个孩子。她帮助他变得更胖了。对。
And I think he's quite a fun father. So he says to his infant son, become a lawyer and I'll hang you. I've said that to my son. I think that's good paternal advice, isn't it? Yeah. Never be alone, act foolish and play, drink a lot. It would even be a good idea to commit a sin, but not a gross one. That's how he advises his children to avoid depression. Yeah. That's good advice. Yeah. Have a bit of fun, but don't go too far. Yeah, exactly. And I think that all of this is kind of an expression of what we were talking about before, how because Luther sees all humans as irredeemably steeped in sin, well, irredeemably, unless God, of course, does choose to redeem them,
我认为他是一个相当有趣的父亲。所以他对他的幼子说，成为一名律师，我就把你吊死。我也对我儿子说过那样的话。我认为那是很好的父亲建议，不是吗？是的。永远不要独处，表现得愚蠢和玩耍，多喝酒。甚至犯个罪也是个好主意，但不要犯大罪。这就是他建议他的孩子如何避免抑郁的方法。是的。那是很好的建议。是的。找点乐子，但不要走得太远。是的，正是如此。我认为这一切都是我们之前谈论的内容的一种表达，因为路德认为所有人类都无可救药地沉浸在罪恶中，好吧，除非上帝当然选择救赎他们，
to allow them to be born again. In a sense, it doesn't really matter. You're not going to get closer to heaven by being a killjoy, celibate all your life. Yeah. Tom, he's gone back up on my estimation because that seems like a very sane and healthy view. We're all damned, unless God, of course, redeems us. We're all weak and feeble. Don't beat yourself up about having a night on the town. That's basically his attitude, is it? Not exactly. But I think he thinks that certainly when it comes to marrying, you might as well. I mean, you know, you're not going to get any closer to heaven by not marrying. Right.
允许他们重生。在某种意义上，这并不重要。你不会因为终身禁欲、扫兴而更接近天堂。是的。汤姆，他在我心中的评价又回升了，因为那看起来是一个非常理智和健康的观点。我们都被诅咒了，除非上帝当然救赎我们。我们都很软弱无力。不要因为在城里过了一夜而自责。这基本上是他的态度，是吗？不完全是。但我认为他认为，当然当谈到结婚时，你最好还是结婚。我的意思是，你知道，你不会因为不结婚而更接近天堂。对。
Right. So that's put Luther in good light, perhaps, by your standards. But now we come to the more splenetic ways in which Luther responds to the Peasants' Revolt. So the couple of months before the Battle of Frankenhausen, when the war is at its most vicious in Saxony and Thuringia, Luther goes on a tour of Thuringia, preaching to all the rebellious peasants, all the rebellious miners, and is very, very unsettled by it. In May, he publishes a pamphlet that to this day remains very controversial, absolutely ensured that he
对。所以这可能按照你的标准把路德放在了一个好的位置。但现在我们谈谈路德回应农民起义的更尖刻的方式。所以，在弗兰肯豪森战役前几个月，当战争在萨克森和图林根最激烈的时候，路德在图林根进行了一次巡回布道，向所有叛乱的农民、所有叛乱的矿工布道，并对此感到非常非常不安。5月，他出版了一本至今仍极具争议的小册子，绝对确保了他
would not feature on East German banknotes. This is a pamphlet called Against the Robbing and the Murdering Hordes of Peasants, which is a very Daily Telegraph headline. I was just thinking the Daily Telegraph would love that. So he'd actually published an earlier pamphlet in which he'd been more ambivalent, kind of basically saying the peasants and princes are both awful, just stop it. But now he gives the rebels both barrels. So, I think there is not a devil left in hell, he writes. They have all gone into the peasants. And then he urges in this very, very notorious phrase, stab, smite, slay whoever you can. And that is directed at the princes.
不会出现在东德的钞票上。这是一本名为《反对抢劫和谋杀的农民暴徒》的小册子，这是一个非常《每日电讯报》式的标题。我刚才就在想《每日电讯报》会喜欢那个。所以他实际上出版了一本更早的小册子，在其中他更矛盾，基本上说农民和诸侯都很糟糕，停下来吧。但现在他给了叛军双重打击。所以，我认为地狱里没有剩下的魔鬼了，他写道。他们都进入了农民体内。然后他用这个非常非常臭名昭著的短语敦促，刺、打、杀，无论你能杀谁。这是针对诸侯的。
And many, many of his admirers are appalled. But Luther never repents it. He never regrets it. I mean, he does condemn atrocities against the peasants. So Munster's wife is raped after the Battle of Frankenhausen, and he condemns that very, very firmly. He condemns the blinding of 60 peasants who supposedly had failed to look at a Lutheran lord in a respectful manner. But despite these atrocities, he continues to feel that divine justice has prevailed. And that is expressive of this inner dread of the devil that has been with him all the way through and of his hatred for the agents of the devil. And we talked about the relish he has for violence
他的许多许多崇拜者感到震惊。但路德从未忏悔。他从未后悔。我的意思是，他确实谴责了针对农民的暴行。所以闵采尔的妻子在弗兰肯豪森战役后被强奸，他非常非常坚定地谴责了这一点。他谴责了60名农民被弄瞎，他们据称未能以尊重的态度看待一位路德宗领主。但尽管有这些暴行，他仍然觉得神圣的正义已经占了上风。这表达了他内心对魔鬼的恐惧，这种恐惧一直伴随着他，以及他对魔鬼代理人的仇恨。我们谈到了他从暴力中获得的快感
in his language. I think there is a relish for violence when it is targeted against people who he sees as the devil's agents. And is this, Tom, psychologically? Because ultimately, Luther is quite conservative. Yeah, he is. I mean, he's from a fairly upwardly mobile, respectable background. Although he likes going against the authority of the institutions that he's in, the university, the church, whatever. Ultimately, he doesn't want to see the social order turned upside down. He doesn't want to live in a millenarian paradise.
在他的语言中。我认为当暴力针对他视为魔鬼代理人的人时，有一种快感。汤姆，这是心理上的吗？因为归根结底，路德是相当保守的。是的，他是。我的意思是，他来自一个相当向上流动、受人尊敬的背景。虽然他喜欢违抗他所在的机构、大学、教会等的权威。归根结底，他不想看到社会秩序被颠覆。他不想生活在一个千禧年的天堂里。
I think he, I mean, he's owed everything to the elector, the figure of the elector, Frederick. Of course, yeah. And there's no reason why he would regard the overthrow of that regime as being something that God would want. I think it's different, say, if you are being raised in a Swiss city. Because as you said, then the scope for envisaging a different social order is much greater. But I think it's also expressive of a dread that disorder is the devil's way of trying to overthrow everything that Luther is doing. And I think that's sharpened by probably, I don't want to over-psychologize it, but the fact that Luther himself has precipitated this great ruction perhaps means that he is, you know,
我认为他，我的意思是，他欠选侯，选侯弗里德里希这个人物的一切。当然，是的。没有理由认为他会把推翻那个政权视为上帝想要的东西。我认为如果你是在瑞士城市长大的，情况就不同了。因为正如你所说，那么设想不同社会秩序的空间要大得多。但我认为这也表达了一种恐惧，即混乱是魔鬼试图推翻路德正在做的一切的方式。我认为这可能被，我不想过度心理分析它，但路德本人引发了这场巨大的冲突，这可能意味着他，你知道，
there's a bit of displacement going on. It's certainly that sense that people who resemble him, who are the particular targets of his hatred. And actually the most notorious example of this isn't the peasants, but the Jews. And even more notorious in the pamphlet he writes against the peasants is a pamphlet he writes just three years before his death in 1546. So it comes out in 1543 called On the Jews and Their Lies. Yeah, I wondered if we could answer this. Right. So, I mean, we can't talk about Luther and not discuss this because in the episode we did on the Nuremberg rallies, we talked about how at the 1934 Nuremberg rally,
发生了一些置换。这当然是一种感觉，即那些像他的人，那些是他仇恨的特定目标。实际上，最臭名昭著的例子不是农民，而是犹太人。甚至比他在反对农民的小册子中更臭名昭著的是他在1546年去世前三年写的一本小册子。所以它在1543年出版，名为《论犹太人及其谎言》。是的，我想知道我们是否能回答这个问题。对。所以，我的意思是，我们不能谈论路德而不讨论这一点，因为在我们做的关于纽伦堡集会的剧集中，我们谈到了在1934年的纽伦堡集会上，
a copy of this pamphlet was on display. And the language is terrible. So you have all his customary cloacal obsessions. So he says of the Jews, and by this point, I think people who've made it this far will recognize the authentic Lutheran touch in this. The devil stuffs and squirts the Jews so full that it overflows and swims out of every place. Pure devil's filth. Yes, it tastes so good to their hearts and they guzzle it like sows. So that's shocking enough. But what's really shocking are the things that Luther demands should be done to the Jews. I mean, Luther is writing, of course, before the Holocaust, but even so. When you read the pamphlet and you read Luther's demands that the jews be rounded up that they all be housed in one place beneath a single roof that they be put to hard labor that the talmud their scriptures their
这本小册子的副本在展出。语言很糟糕。所以你有他所有习惯性的排泄物痴迷。所以他谈到犹太人，到这个时候，我想读到这里的人会认出其中地道的路德式风格。魔鬼把犹太人塞得满满的，以至于它溢出来，从每个地方流出来。纯粹的魔鬼污秽。是的，它尝起来对他们的心很好，他们像母猪一样狼吞虎咽。所以这已经够令人震惊了。但真正令人震惊的是路德要求对犹太人做的事情。我的意思是，路德当然是在大屠杀之前写的，但即便如此。当你读这本小册子，读到路德要求把犹太人围捕起来，把他们都安置在一个地方，在同一个屋檐下，让他们从事苦役，他们的塔木德、他们的经文、他们的
synagogues should be burnt and that then to quote luther whatever will not burn should be buried and covered with dirt so that no man will ever again see so much as a stone or cinder of them i mean it is chilling yeah and the nazis loved this right the nazis embraced luther as one of their own yeah of course and i think it's it's doubly disturbing for admirers of luther both because i mean this is this is shocking even by the standards of the time as with the peasants people who admire Luther are really appalled to read this. They kind of think he's really gone too far with this. And the other thing that's disturbing about it is that it's not just a rehashing of
犹太教堂应该被烧毁，然后引用路德的话，任何烧不掉的东西都应该被埋葬并覆盖上泥土，这样就再也没有人能看到哪怕是一块石头或灰烬。我的意思是，这令人不寒而栗。是的，纳粹喜欢这个，对吧？纳粹拥抱路德作为他们自己人。是的，当然。我认为这对路德的崇拜者来说是双重不安的，因为我的意思是，这即使按照当时的标准也是令人震惊的，正如对待农民一样，崇拜路德的人读到这些真的很震惊。他们有点认为他在这一点上真的走得太远了。关于它的另一件令人不安的事情是，它不仅仅是反犹主义的重弹。
antisemitism. So basically what precipitates this is Luther's feeling that it is those who have been granted rebirth by God. So we could probably call them Protestants now without risk of anachronism, because that word is starting to be used by the time Luther writes this pamphlet, that they are God's chosen people, and that therefore the Jews claiming to be God's chosen people, that it's cast by Luther as stupidity and folly and arrogance. So that idea of we have been chosen and they are our antithesis because they rejected the word. I mean, that you could, if you were being harsh to
所以基本上导致这种情况的是路德的感觉，即那些被上帝赋予重生的人。所以我们现在可能可以称他们为新教徒，而没有时代错误的风险，因为当路德写这本小册子时，那个词已经开始被使用了，他们是上帝的选民，因此犹太人声称自己是上帝的选民，这被路德斥为愚蠢、愚昧和傲慢。所以那种“我们被选中了，而他们是我们的对立面，因为他们拒绝了话语”的想法。我的意思是，如果你对路德很苛刻，
Luther, you could say, well, doesn't that very clearly anticipate the Nazi idea that you talked about when you did that brilliant episode about Nazi ideology? The idea that they have been chosen by nature to be the supermen. They are the enlightened ones. They are the representatives of nobility and the human spirit and all that is best. And the Nazis believe that the Jews were their complete sort of bestial antithesis. That's kind of what Luther is saying right now. Okay, he's not talking about nature, he's talking about God, but he thinks Protestants are the elect and that the Jews are the opposite. But that's really important. He's not condem about nature, he's talking about God, but he thinks Protestants are the elect and the Jews are the opposite. But that's really important. He's not condemning the Jews as a race. So that's what the Nazis are doing.
你可以说，好吧，那不是非常清楚地预示了你在做那集关于纳粹意识形态的精彩剧集时谈到的纳粹思想吗？那种他们被自然选中成为超人的想法。他们是开明的人。他们是贵族和人类精神以及所有最好事物的代表。而纳粹认为犹太人是他们完全的某种兽性对立面。路德现在说的就是那种意思。好吧，他不是在谈论自然，他是在谈论上帝，但他认为新教徒是选民，而犹太人是相反的。但这真的很重要。他不是在谴责犹太人作为一个种族。所以这就是纳粹在做的事情。
He's condemning them as pretenders to the title that belonged to, as he sees it, God's elect, which is people like him. So it is theologically based rather than racially based. I mean, I'm sure that's not much comfort to Jewish listeners. But Tom, the idea of a dichotomy, the idea of this kind of us and them, that the Jews are the supreme villains. They're not the supreme villains. So he doesn't think they're the supreme villains. Well, you know, they're to be condemned together with, you know, Catholics or whatever. Okay. So they're one villain among many. Yeah. Or Munzer's followers. Okay. So they're one villain among many. Yeah. Or Munster's followers. It's fair to say that Luther is a good hater. He expresses his
他是在谴责他们作为属于，正如他所见，上帝选民的头衔的冒充者，也就是像他这样的人。所以它是基于神学的，而不是基于种族的。我的意思是，我相信这对犹太听众来说没什么安慰。但是汤姆，二分法的想法，这种“我们和他们”的想法，犹太人是至高无上的恶棍。他们不是至高无上的恶棍。所以他不认为他们是至高无上的恶棍。好吧，你知道，他们要和，你知道，天主教徒或其他什么人一起被谴责。好吧。所以他们是众多恶棍中的一个。是的。或者闵采尔的追随者。好吧。所以他们是众多恶棍中的一个。是的。或者闵采尔的追随者。公平地说，路德是一个很好的仇恨者。他表达了他的
opinions very robustly. And so that's what enables him to precipitate the Reformation. And it occasionally leads him to shocking extremes. He's not a saint. But then against that, I suppose, theologically speaking, Luther never claimed to be a saint. I mean, his whole point is that humanity has fallen. So inevitably he's a sinner. That's the whole point of it. So that's why I think it's possible to admire Luther's courage, his insights, while the fact that he wrote what he wrote about the peasants and wrote what he wrote about the Jews doesn't disqualify the quality of his insights. Because from Luther's point of view, he's fallen. He's part of humanity. All of humanity has fallen.
观点非常有力。这就是使他能够引发宗教改革的原因。它偶尔会导致他走向令人震惊的极端。他不是圣人。但反过来，我想，从神学上讲，路德从未声称自己是圣人。我的意思是，他的全部观点是人类已经堕落了。所以不可避免地他是一个罪人。这就是全部意义所在。所以我认为这就是为什么有可能钦佩路德的勇气、他的见解，而他写下关于农民和犹太人的东西并不能取消他见解的质量。因为从路德的角度来看，他堕落了。他是人类的一部分。全人类都堕落了。
But that's quite convenient, isn't it, Tom? I'm a bad man, but I'm fallen. No, I think he has struggled with this all his life. It's not like it's been easy for him. I mean, he has risked his life to make this case. But he would say, I suppose that his relationship with God has been this kind of great love affair, but that God is God, he is fallen and human. And so he is capable of sin in a way obviously that god is not i guess would be his perspective if you were summing luther up so thinking about sort of i mean it's a silly way of doing it debits and credits but luther is obviously an immensely brave man and he's
但这很方便，不是吗，汤姆？我是一个坏人，但我堕落了。不，我认为他一生都在为此挣扎。这对他来说并不容易。我的意思是，他冒着生命危险来提出这个理由。但他会说，我想他与上帝的关系一直是这种伟大的爱情故事，但上帝是上帝，他是堕落和人类的。所以他有能力犯罪，而上帝显然没有，我想如果总结路德，这会是他的观点。所以考虑到，我的意思是，这是一种愚蠢的做法，借方和贷方，但路德显然是一个极其勇敢的人，他
intellectually formidable and he has a charisma because otherwise he wouldn't have inspired all these people against that i suppose you would say, he's an unbelievably, I mean, you use the word egocentrism. He can be very narcissistic, I would say, thinking that the peasants' war has been set by the devil. His estimation of himself is, I mean, it's even higher, Tom, than our estimation of ourselves
在智力上是强大的，他有一种魅力，因为否则他不会激励所有这些人。反对这一点，我想你会说，他是一个令人难以置信的，我的意思是，你用了“自我中心”这个词。他可能非常自恋，我会说，认为农民战争是魔鬼设置的。他对自己的评价，我的意思是，汤姆，甚至比我们对自己的评价还要高
on the rest is history. And he's incredibly ungenerous, isn't he? He's an ungenerous man to his opponents. To his enemies, for sure. Yeah. There's a violence in him, which is not necessarily there in other people with courage and intellect and all of those things. Would you not agree with that? Yeah. I think the strain of violence in his language is very evident. I mean, against that, from the beginning, for instance, he is against the idea that, say, heretics should be burned. I mean, he never actually kills anyone.
在《历史余谈》上。而且他非常吝啬，不是吗？他是一个对对手吝啬的人。对他的敌人，当然。是的。他身上有一种暴力，这在其他有勇气和智慧以及所有这些品质的人身上不一定存在。你不同意吗？是的。我认为他语言中的暴力倾向非常明显。我的意思是，反过来，从一开始，例如，他反对异端应该被烧死的想法。我的意思是，他从未真正杀过任何人。
He doesn't take up arms. He writes abusive pamphlets. Yeah. But, you know, if you write abusive editorials in newspapers and that's going to send you to hell, Dominic, then… Don't go there, Tom. Don't go there. Let he who is without sin cast the first stone.
他没有拿起武器，而是写了谩骂的小册子。是的。但是，你知道，如果你在报纸上写谩骂的社论，而这会让你下地狱，多米尼克，那么……别去那儿，汤姆。别去那儿。让没有罪的人先扔石头吧。
Yeah, that's not a parallel I'm keen to explore. Yeah. Listen, before we get onto Luther's legacy, just one quick thing. I know you'll find this absolutely impossible, which is why I'm asking you to do it. But you said we could use the word Protestants and Protestantism by this stage. So very, very briefly, is the story effectively that by the end of the 1520s it has just gone too far so that by the time the authorities think let's try and put a lid on this that ship has sailed yeah yeah so by the time he dies in 1546 yeah protestantism has now become entrenched in large parts of germany
是的，我不打算探讨这个类比。听着，在我们进入路德的遗产之前，先说一件小事。我知道你会觉得这绝对不可能，这就是我要求你做的原因。但你说过我们在这个阶段可以使用“新教徒”和“新教”这两个词。所以，非常简短地问一下，故事是否实际上是这样的：到1520年代末，事情已经发展得太远了，以至于当当局想要控制局面时，已经为时已晚了？是的，是的，所以到他1546年去世时，新教已经在德国大部分地区根深蒂固了。
it has spread to the baltic it spread to Scandinavia. It's obviously the ideas have spread to England through Anne Boleyn and through all these sort of people importing books and things. And is that effectively what's happened? And is Luther happy with that? Does he think, great, brilliant, this is what I wanted? Or does he think this has gone completely out of control? I think he, I mean, he's very happy that there are Lutheran regimes in princely states in Germany and in Scandinavia and the Baltic. I think he's more conflicted about the Protestantism of Switzerland and definitely in England. I mean, he thinks Henry VIII is mad. But I mean, whatever form Protestantism takes, he'd rather that than what had existed before. Really? Yeah. And do you think he almost self-radicalized? So he never goes back and thinks, well, maybe I was a bit too harsh on the Pope. No, he never does that. No. I mean,
它已经传播到波罗的海，传播到斯堪的纳维亚。显然，这些思想通过安妮·博林以及所有那些进口书籍的人传播到了英国。这基本上就是发生的事情吗？路德对此感到高兴吗？他认为“太棒了，这正是我想要的”吗？还是他认为这已经完全失控了？我想，我的意思是，他非常高兴在德国的诸侯国、斯堪的纳维亚和波罗的海有路德宗政权。我认为他对瑞士以及绝对是英国的新教感到更加矛盾。我的意思是，他认为亨利八世是个疯子。但我的意思是，无论新教采取什么形式，他都宁愿要它，而不是之前存在的东西。真的吗？是的。你认为他几乎是自我激进化了吗？所以他从来没有回头想过，也许我对教皇太苛刻了？不，他从来没有那样做。不。我的意思是，
he has self-radicalized. The first five years of the Reformation essentially are down to Luther self-radicalizing. And we've compared him to Elvis at various points over this. He's the king. He is kind of setting rock and roll on its path. Then he gets drafted. Then he comes back and he does his films. And then he kind of ends up fat eating burgers on the toilet. And so most of this series has been very much focused on that kind of central five-year period where he changes the world. And there is a sense of him, a slight kind of vagus quality to his final decades. I mean, we've barely discussed them.
他已经自我激进化了。宗教改革的前五年基本上归结为路德的自我激进化。我们在这一点上多次将他比作猫王。他是国王。他正在为摇滚乐开辟道路。然后他被征召入伍。然后他回来拍电影。最后他变得肥胖，在厕所里吃汉堡。所以这个系列的大部分内容都非常集中在那五年左右的核心时期，他改变了世界。在他最后的几十年里，有一种轻微的模糊感。我的意思是，我们几乎没有讨论过它们。
I mean, things are still going on, but they're less dramatic and he's not at the head of the Reformation by this point. And the world that he creates, Tom, in your notes, you've used these three isms, atheism, secularism, individualism. So the idea of thinking for yourself, not being told that your personal truth, your conscience. Atheism because he's thinking- Because his great argument is that sola scriptura, if it's not in the Bible, get rid of it. And so expressive of a kind of profound scepticism towards the inheritance of a religious tradition. So it gets rid of all kinds of dogmas from the medieval church. But the logical implication of that is that, you know,
我的意思是，事情仍在继续，但戏剧性较小，而且此时他不再是宗教改革的领袖。而他创造的世界，汤姆，在你的笔记中，你用了这三个“主义”：无神论、世俗主义、个人主义。所以，独立思考的想法，不被告知你的个人真理、你的良心。无神论是因为他在思考——因为他伟大的论点是“唯独圣经”，如果圣经里没有，就把它扔掉。因此，这表达了一种对宗教传统继承的深刻怀疑。所以它摆脱了中世纪教会的各种教条。但其逻辑含义是，你知道，
why only scripture? Why not get rid of scripture as well? And essentially that is the kind of the end point that Protestant countries can arrive at. The whole process that gets initiated with Karlstadt and then with Munster and so on, that you overthrow traditional expressions of piety in the form of icons and so on, that these are idols, that they have to be toppled, all superstition. Again, you get rid of all that, you end up getting rid of everything. The process of reformation, I think, logically ends with atheism, which is why so many prominent atheists and humanists sound so Protestant. They are evangelical. Richard Dawkins, yeah. Yeah. Get rid of it and you'll gain enlightenment. You will gain the truth. You will feel in your
为什么只有圣经？为什么不把圣经也扔掉？本质上，这就是新教国家可能达到的终点。整个过程始于卡尔施塔特，然后是明斯特等等，你推翻了以圣像等形式存在的传统虔诚表达，认为这些是偶像，必须被推翻，全是迷信。同样，你摆脱了所有这些，最终你摆脱了一切。我认为宗教改革的过程在逻辑上以无神论告终，这就是为什么这么多著名的无神论者和人文主义者听起来如此像新教徒。他们是福音派。理查德·道金斯，是的。是的。摆脱它，你就会获得启蒙。你就会获得真理。你会感觉到你的
heart that you're a better person. I mean, this is pure Luther, but without God. And secularism, for the reasons that we were talking about earlier, the idea that it refines the idea of what religion is and counterpoints it to something called the secular. And again, I mean, Luther would have been appalled to imagine that he had a role to play in the emergence of any of those trends, but it doesn't stop him from playing that role. And just one last question before we wrap up what has been. I mean, I found this one of the most intellectually fascinating subjects that we've ever done on the rest is history, to be honest.
内心深处，你是一个更好的人。我的意思是，这是纯粹的路德，但没有上帝。还有世俗主义，出于我们之前讨论的原因，它细化了宗教的概念，并将其与所谓的“世俗”相对照。同样，我的意思是，路德如果想象到他在这些趋势的出现中扮演了角色，他会感到震惊，但这并不能阻止他扮演这个角色。在我们结束之前，还有一个问题，那就是——老实说，我发现这是我们在《历史的其余部分》中做过的最引人入胜的主题之一。
What if Luther had never lived or he'd been carried off by smallpox in the 1510s or something? So is there an argument that all of these things, the rise of individualism, the rise of the idea of the secular, people challenging the authority
如果路德从未出生，或者他在1510年代死于天花之类的疾病会怎样？那么，是否有一种论点认为所有这些事情，个人主义的兴起，世俗观念的兴起，人们挑战权威
of inherited traditions and dogmas, indeed institutions like the Catholic Church, and the fact that people are thinking of this in Switzerland at the same time, for example. Could you be a skeptic and say, listen, Luther is actually just surface froth, and the underlying shifts would have happened anyway with the arrival of the printing press and the fragmentation of authority in Central Europe and so on and so forth? Or would you say, no, he's a genius and he does change history and individuals do matter? I mean, a seeming parallel might be Darwinism. Would the theory of evolution have been found without Darwin? Probably it would. But I think actually the thing about Luther is that it's a
继承的传统和教条，甚至是像天主教会这样的机构，以及人们同时在瑞士思考这个问题的事实，等等。你能不能做一个怀疑论者，说：听着，路德实际上只是表面的泡沫，随着印刷机的到来和中欧权威的碎片化等等，潜在的转变无论如何都会发生？还是你会说，不，他是一个天才，他确实改变了历史，个人确实很重要？我的意思是，一个看似平行的例子可能是达尔文主义。如果没有达尔文，进化论会被发现吗？可能确实会。但我认为关于路德的事情是，它是一种
personal experience of God. The intellectual materials for Darwin to construct his theory are there, which is why Wallace is also coming up with it at the same time. For Luther, it's that individual sense of God that you can experience grace in the way that Luther experiences it. Then when he describes it, loads of other people across Christendom discover that they can have the same experience too. It's that personal experience combined with Luther's exceptional ability to promote his understanding of God's purposes, which of course is dependent on the printing press, absolutely. But to exploit a medium, you need to have the ability to do that. So it's that combination of Luther's personal experience of God and his command of language and ability to promote his takes, I think, that makes him so decisive. And I think that you would have had bushfires of heresy blazing out. I mean, they've been happening forever, but not in the seismic way that it does in the early 16th century. So I really do think that Luther makes a difference.
对上帝的个人体验。达尔文构建其理论的智力材料是存在的，这就是为什么华莱士同时也提出了这个理论。对于路德来说，那种个人的上帝感，即你可以以路德体验它的方式体验恩典。然后当他描述它时，整个基督教世界的许多其他人发现他们也可以有同样的体验。正是这种个人体验与路德推广其上帝旨意理解的非凡能力相结合，当然，这取决于印刷机，绝对是这样。但是要利用一种媒介，你需要有能力这样做。所以我认为，正是路德对上帝的个人体验与他对语言的掌控以及推广其观点的能力相结合，使他如此具有决定性。我确实认为你会看到异端的野火在燃烧。我的意思是，它们一直在发生，但不是像16世纪初那样以地震般的方式。所以我真的认为路德确实带来了改变。
Okay, brilliant. Well, after five episodes, I mean, you've got to say that. Well, not necessarily. The Titanic, I think we spent six episodes, didn't we? And we said, oh, it was just an accident. Yeah, it means nothing. I think that's the conclusion yeah i know this has been rich in meaning tom and in uh extraordinary color i've really enjoyed doing it and for those of you i can't believe there's anybody who's tired of
好的，太棒了。好吧，五集之后，我的意思是，你必须这么说。嗯，不一定。泰坦尼克号，我想我们花了六集，对吧？我们说，哦，那只是个意外。是的，它毫无意义。我认为这就是结论，是的，我知道这很有意义，汤姆，而且有非凡的色彩，我真的很喜欢做这个。对于那些——我不敢相信有人会厌倦
reformation theology but if you are tired of it and you're craving something different then next week we will be walking on the moon with a special guest we will be in the discos of new york city in the 1970s and then after that we will be going to greece to the ottoman empire and to the um to the very limits of human hedonism tom i think it's fair to say with lord byron the first international celebrity. Is that your claim? Yeah. So we've got Lord Byron to come.
宗教改革神学，但如果你厌倦了它，渴望一些不同的东西，那么下周我们将带着一位特别嘉宾在月球上行走，我们将进入1970年代纽约市的迪斯科舞厅，然后在那之后，我们将前往希腊，前往奥斯曼帝国，前往人类享乐主义的极限，汤姆，我认为可以说，与第一位国际名人拜伦勋爵一起。这是你的主张吗？是的。所以我们有拜伦勋爵要来。
We have space. We have discos. In the future, we will be doing all kinds of things from Native Americans and the Trojan War to Bonnie Prince Charlie and the Normandy landings. So loads of interesting things to come. And we will see you next time. Thank you very much. Bye-bye.
我们有太空。我们有迪斯科。在未来，我们将做各种各样的事情，从美洲原住民和特洛伊战争到邦尼王子查理和诺曼底登陆。所以有很多有趣的事情要来。我们下次见。非常感谢。再见。
Bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。